I want to I want to work on two features
at the same time. So, we're going to
show off that workflow. But then there's
a thing I want to actually make me
better at context switching.
>> You cannot out outsource the thinking,
man. I mean, that's the thing I've
learned in working in complex systems is
like if you don't come with opinions,
the model will not I mean, you could ask
the model to do that, but like if you
know what you want, just tell the model
what you want. That's my advice. Hey,
look at that.
>> Wow,
>> it's there cuz now it's just pulling it
from the database. So, any one of these
that has the thing in the database is
going to work. [music]
All right, we are live. We're going to
do some live coding today. I'm super
stoked. Um, welcome to the AI That Works
podcast where we show you real practical
examples of how to use AI that works. We
do a lot of live coding. We do a lot of
whiteboarding. Um, I'm Dex. I'm the
founder of Human Layer. We build tools
to help you solve hard problems with
coding agents. I'm going to pass it over
to Vibb.
>> Hey everyone, I'm Vivof. I build BAML.
Uh we try and make tools that make it
really easy to reduce increase the
reliability of L1 pipelines.
>> Amazing. And what are we working on
today?
>> I think today is going to be a fun live
coding session. We've done we've done
one more of these in the past and you
and I have obviously live coded
together. But I think today I wanted to
go ahead and go deep into that
conversation and just go really hard
into understanding uh and not just
understand but showing some features
here. But also I want to add some
features to the code layer that I've
been wanting myself uh and that you have
around to.
>> Last time we did I I I coded up a BAML
feature and Vibb was navigating. Today
we're going to do Vibb's going to drive.
He's going to write the code layer
features that he's always wanted and I'm
going to help navigate. So, why don't we
do this? Why don't I start? Um, I will
share and we can do a quick little
whiteboard of just like the the three
things we talked about building today
and then we'll get right to it and this
will probably be a little bit of a
longer episode which is going to be a
fun time. Amazing. Okay. So, feature
number one is AI summaries
or like AI generated session titles,
right?
>> Exactly.
And I guess everyone knows what we're
talking about. Let me put a snippet of
uh code learner in there so then people
know exactly what I'm trying to do.
>> Oh, screenshot.
>> Yeah, I'll include one. So, the idea is
that in this tool I want a couple of
things. One, I hate manually adding this
title in every single time. It's a
really small thing, but it's very
similar to chat GBT where chat GPT
autotitles every chat that you're into.
It's really nice.
>> The other thing that I want
>> you're talking about up here basically.
>> Exactly. I don't want to manually type
that in. The other thing that I want is
sometimes you open markdown files and uh
code generates a lot of markdown files
especially during the planning phases. I
personally love using Obsidian for it.
Obsidian is amazing. Um I want to open
those files in Obsidian and that's a
little bit trickier because Obsidian
really works off of vaults, not really
pure files. So we'll have to go manage
that system and understand it.
>> Yeah. So, just to show um what he's
talking about, we have this option in
the settings where you can pick your
default editor and then when you're
editing a file or something, you can
quickly pop this open in VS Code or
something just to view that file
directly.
>> The last part is a part that not a lot
of people think about when they're live
coding. Um, which is how do you actually
context switch really really quickly?
Now, context switching I think is the
most important part. Oh, there you go.
Yeah, you can show that off. So you can
show Yeah, you can just open this file
in your editor.
>> Yeah. And personally looking at markdown
files in VS Code is trash. So I'm not
going to do that with my life.
>> You're entitled to your opinion, man.
>> My opinions are correct opinions. Um
>> uh probably.
>> But h No, I'm just joking. But
regardless of that fact is like I just
want to make it really easy as a
developer to do like Mark a lot of I
think there's there's a subtlety here
that not a lot of people think about
which is just like how are you what
what's the kind of work that you're
doing when you're doing work in um in
like planning mode or generating specs.
You're actually doing a lot more reading
than writing. And while code is really
really good because of syntax
highlighting in like dark mode, the it
turns out there's a lot of research that
shows [laughter] that
>> specifically dark mode.
>> Well, code is really good in dark mode
because uh like the high contrast makes
it really easy to like understand the
[snorts] flow and the structure of code
>> because of syntax keywords.
>> But on the other hand, markdown files
aren't actually high contrast because
they just have headers and they're it's
contrasting the right thing. And what
you actually need to do is you actually
need to read the words carefully. And
when you're actually reading the words
carefully, what you really need to do in
that scenario is you actually do need to
um
like let your eyes not just gloss over
it. In that context, light mode is just
better. Light mode has been shown to be
significantly better at reading large
like reading specs. There's a lot of
research on this. I can share this in a
bit. So now this what I want to do is I
want to use the best tool for that job
which is in my opinion obsidian. Um,
>> you know, they have a dark mode. You
could use it in in dark mode.
>> Why would you do that? The default is
light mode for [laughter] a reason.
>> Okay. All right. All right.
>> But as we go down this road, um, and
then the third feature I want to talk
about is actually context switching. And
I hope we can we can show this off in
the time that we have today. And the
reason for that is because context
switching is one of the most important
parts when you're doing AI codegen of
any kind. And
>> because it's slow, right? You're often
waiting a lot and so you're going to
work on multiple things in parallel.
>> Exactly. I want to I want to work on two
features at the same time. So we're
going to show off that workflow, but
then there's a thing I want to actually
make me better at context switching
because context switching is an
expensive process. It's expensive for
programs, expensive context switching is
the most expensive thing you do in your
software. Anytime you do
multi-threading, threading context and
swapping that over is expensive. Async
contexts are expensive to swap over.
>> [snorts]
>> So, we want to go try and solve that
problem here for a human.
>> And I want to do that by doing a quick
thing, which is every single time I look
at a certain previous message, I want it
to both remind me what I was doing
really quickly in like one or two
sentences, remind me the directory I was
last working in, and also remind me what
it thinks I should be doing next. Uh
whether it's like actually reviewing the
plan, whether it's like implementing the
plan, whether it's looking at a certain
phase, I just wanted to like quickly
remind me that context.
>> [snorts]
>> Um, and I don't know where it's going to
go in the UI. I haven't thought about
that. But I just want that reminder for
myself because I'll get much faster at
it. So, without further ado, I think we
should just go straight to doing this.
And part of this is we're going to do
the first two.
>> I have one thing we should do first. Um,
and this is the thing I always do. I
always say is like when you're doing
this stuff, it's it's helpful to have at
least one person who's really good at
the workflow of research plan implement.
And you need someone who's an expert at
the code. Um I'm gonna propose we spend
two minutes. I'm just going to draw a
little architecture diagram of the parts
of the system so that we have shared
language while we're talking about this.
>> Let's do it.
>> And so what matters here is in the code
layer stack you have uh tower which is
the back end of the desktop app. You
have what we call the wooi. This is a
vit application. This is just a plain
front end application that gets run by.
Tower will also launch a process called
CLLD, which is the code layer demon,
which for legacy reasons launches a
process called HLD, which is the human
layer demon. This is in Go. We're moving
it to TypeScript. And why we're doing
this is like through the strangler
pattern. So, right now, most traffic
gets proxied from the web app, makes
REST calls to CLD, and just gets proxied
straight through. um for the new stuff
because of the value of like having the
cloud SDK in Typescript, we're just
going to write new endpoints uh into
CLLD for the new like AI summarization
stuff.
>> Cool. Uh so the title summaries and
everything else live in there.
>> Yeah. And then this is going to talk to
a SQLite database and then this SQLite
database goes through endpoints here
which is used to like seccee and send
updates down to the web app.
>> Got it. So th that's the I think that's
the basics of the architecture. Any like
questions here?
>> Can I ask you a quick question really
fast? Um since we're doing this in a
time frame, I feel like it's going to be
probably hard to get the data spin up a
new pipeline that uh initializes in CLLD
and then goes into HLD and spins back
around.
>> Uh yeah. So the idea is literally um the
the vap will invoke the cloud SDK from
here. And so we're not going to go all
the way to SLD. We're not going to
store.
Oh, because we do want to store this in
the
>> data. That's why it's going to be really
complicated otherwise.
>> Okay. Yeah, we can add a new endpoint
into HLD.
>> That's what I figured that. And by the
way, these are the kinds of
conversations that we can have in like 2
minutes.
>> Actually, I'm going to I'm going to I'm
going to I'm going to I'm going to do
another pitch because the HLD has an
endpoint for like post slash session ID
update title. I'm going to I'm going to
suggest just cuz like this isn't going
to be the final state of this code, but
as we're in this like migration state, I
say the endpoint here, front end gets it
back and then sends it to HLD to update
the title.
>> So, [snorts] I'll make another
proposition really fast.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the place that I was going to do
this was the create session tab.
>> So, when you create a new session, part
of it that it was going to do was
>> if you provide a session ID, it's just
going to provide one right there. So it
was actually going to be a much faster
change I think.
>> Ah okay. So then yeah. So then you don't
even need to it's just when you
>> updating the method inside HLD.
>> Um so the way the draft launcher works
here like yeah we just see what it does.
>> Uh I think it can be very helpful when
you're implementing to again have your
codebase expert to come with opinions
and especially with this one we have so
many different ways to do it. We should
kind of have an approach in mind.
>> Cool. Let's do it.
>> Um, so I think maybe what we can do is
like when you you're saying when I
launch the session, just have HLD go
make a thing during the session
creation.
>> So I think the best way to do this is I
care I I don't want there to be a lag in
spinning up session cuz like it's just
annoying for the user. So what I was
thinking is you create the session then
the HLD as you named it is going to
create a new background process like a
deferred ghost code routine that is just
going to go ahead at this point and then
spin up a way to like go retitle that
retitle that session.
>> Interesting.
Um
>> yeah because I don't want like it's a
two second lag for every user
>> to create a title and that's freaking
dumb.
>> Okay cool. Um,
>> and since we have Go, we can do a
deferred uh we can do a Go routine
really easily and it'll be really fast.
>> Okay. I'm
I think that should work. I'm curious if
I'm just going to go pull up this
session because we have two we can test
actually the like live updates on the
front end. So, if I go to this say hi
session over here, I've just have two
builds running. But if I edit this here
and change it.
Okay. So on the next message, the title
does update over here. It doesn't live
stream in, but I think that's fine for
now. I think that's for our MVP.
>> If you're doing SSE,
>> we're not doing SSE for title changes
because it's not expected that it
happens asynchronously right now.
>> But we can make that part of the
asynchronous request to go update that
>> to go send an event and have it resync.
Okay,
>> that's part of the RPI process, I would
say.
>> Cool. And yeah, and then my advice is
basically like we'll leave that to a
later phase. Uh cuz we want to make sure
this works and we can test the core of
it and then we'll uh like move on to
optimizing the experience.
>> Cool. Shall I screen share? Do you want
to do it? Do you want to try?
>> Uh yeah, let's let's kick it off. I
think I think that's probably good
enough. Um, and I think one thing that's
probably worth doing is like writing up
the like ticket for I mean we can we
don't have to, but like when we did it
with um the VAML features, we did have
like a somewhat written up like GitHub
issue of the thing we were doing.
>> I will I will just articulate this to
the user and I'll show exactly how I do
this.
>> So I already have the repo spun up. Um I
cloned it out uh and then I can run the
dev version of this. And before even
running the dev version, I'm just going
to start the command. We'll use opus, I
guess. Is that the best model now?
>> Uh, yeah, opus is pretty good for
everything at this point.
>> Uh, code layer
research codebase. Okay,
when a user creates a new session, I
want to create a AI generated title
throughout this process. Now, the AI
generated title should cause no lag. So
what I want to happen is technically the
HLD should spin off a go routine that
creates a
uh that attempts to create a title based
on the session as it's running and the
message that the user gave us and then
after that what I want to happen is it
should send an event to the front end
that actually uh via SSC that actually
tells the model uh that tells the UI
exactly what the new title is. So
therefore there's no lag to the user and
we get AI generated titles. So users
don't have to predict what the title is.
I'd also like some sort of nice UI
indicator to know that we're actually
generating a title in the front end in
this case that it happens so it's not
like randomly changing for the user.
>> I'm going to give you some more things
to add there.
>> Tell me.
>> Are you on are you on headphones or if I
talk will it be able to
>> If you talk it should go in. So, we're
going to want to check for um how Claude
Code sessions are launched um from HLD
via the Claude Code Go library. Um we're
going to be creating a new session with
Haiku and creating it in a temporary
directory. So, this isn't going to go
through the main code path where the
demon like manages a session and tracks
it in the database. This is just going
to be a one-off throwaway disposable
thing where we put in a plain prompt and
we get an answer back. So, we're going
to need to override the system
instructions. We're going to need to run
it in a small tempter so there's no git
or codebase context clouding the system
prompt.
>> Yeah. Can I make a comment on that?
Should we try and do this after we
actually do the research sentence and
then add that in?
>> Yeah. So, I think this is really your
Wait. So, put this in. Hold on. Let's
keep all of this. All of this is
implementation details. And what I like
to do during research is just tell it
the parts of the codebase that are going
to matter without telling it what we're
building. I would almost stash all of
this in a text file and save it for our
planning.
>> That's actually different than how I
approach it. Um
>> I know that's why we're going to
>> do you want to try Okay, I can I can try
your approach, but I was going to try my
approach if you're down for it and just
see what it comes out with and then we
can just backtrack and retry again with
the Obsidian system for years.
>> Okay, let's do this. Let's launch this
one and we'll launch another one in
parallel and then we can compare the two
documents and maybe combine them. The
problem is is this is going to come with
a research that includes lots of
implementation advice which is like when
you do implementation during the
research phase, you don't get good
answers because the model just picks the
first thing it thinks of. Whereas the
the whole point of the planning prompt
is to work back and forth quite a bit in
order to make sure that you're
considering all options. the research
one is just going to dive into okay
here's how we're doing it great that's
how we're doing it and it's going to let
the model decide which is not going to
yield the best results
>> so I have a question for that do you
find that that is necessarily bad u in
the case of like smaller features like
the one that we talked about
>> if you if you already know exactly how
you want to do it then you can sometimes
get away with it I don't think this is a
small feature though like this is
probably like a a day's worth of work if
if you were going to really like go
through and code it by hand or code it
just like tab complete. So, let's do
another research and I will I will give
you like if I were building this not on
a podcast, here's how I would prompt it.
So, you ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, find everywhere about how the demon
launches cloud code sessions through the
cloud code go library. find everything
related to um
how the front end uh creates sessions
and launches draft sessions and uh how
SSC events are streamed down to the
front end and everything about how
titles are set the the logic for
autotitle versus human specified title.
What? Uh, so change SSC to SSE.
Um, and then I'm just going to give you
I I'm going to do another thing which is
like just pulling in documentation. Um,
if you go get the Cloud Code TypeScript
SD or No, we're not going to use that.
Damn. Uh, is there a Cloud Code
SDK like CLI docs?
Because we want to just have all these
flags. I suspect that it'll be easier
than you think here, Dexter.
>> Okay. Yeah. Uh
>> because I think the other research will
mostly do the task. I I can run this if
you want.
>> And we need to look at the
>> Yeah, let's let's see what that looks
like. That's just a double submit. It's
fine. It's working.
>> Okay.
>> The event fired twice. That's a bug.
>> Um and now while we're doing this, it's
going to off actual task.
>> And then we're going to go do the other
one, right?
>> Yeah.
What I want to do here is I really want
to add u the ability to open markdown
files through Obsidian instead of the
default file editor. What are the parts
of the codebase that are relevant for
this?
>> Perfect.
Oh, you're hitting that a lot.
Interesting.
>> That's really interesting. Um it's
probably going to take forever to do
this research. That's why I actually
hate using Opus, to be honest. Well, the
new office is faster and also all of
these sub agents run with sonnet.
>> Oh, do you do you guarantee that or do
you
>> It's hardcoded in the uh in the agent uh
header.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Um you can look at the tool call
actually if you hover over one of those
and hit I uh sorry uh so you can use H
to contract this.
So, not here, but actually the tool call
on the sub agent itself. So, there's no
way to click and open that one. You have
to focus the sub agent and hit I use
>> no use J to go down to the sub agent.
Sorry, I'm going to make you use the Vim
key bindings,
>> right?
>> Uh down. Keep going down until you're
focused on the top level of the sub. So,
go up. Yeah. Now, hit I. So, this will
tell you what prompt was passed to the
sub agent. And sometimes I've seen the
model will actually pick a sub agent. So
sometimes it will like choose haik coup
here. It looks like it's just chosen the
prompts so far.
>> I see.
>> Um and then like just to show why this
is an issue like let's go put titles on
these so we don't lose track of what
they are.
>> Uh this is research uh code
uh research. Uh what am I doing?
Obsidian.
Cool.
That's interesting. Yeah. What I found
is when I go do this, um, it usually
works pretty well without me having to
do too much work. There we go.
Uh, and then it's going to write the
research document. So, this one will
come out. Let's open obsidian
file.
Byopots's working in sync layer, which
is our kind of like preview playground
for uh more experimental stuff.
And then I should get research popping
out pretty soon if this generates stuff
correctly.
And while we're doing this hide
mo gave us the uh CLI reference which is
probably useful.
Um do you want to grab that and add a MD
on the end and kind of we can we can
reference that during the planning.
Let me just read this really fast.
>> Yeah, this is because what happens is
like cloud code go is our library that
wraps the CLI and so it just like if
we're going to make changes to that to
create a new kind of like hey just do a
one-off session that is like text in
text out no tools.
>> I'm going to try this really fast. Can
we just try this and see if this works?
>> Yeah.
>> Um so what do we want? And how do you
delete uh session IDs?
because it'll always create a new
session I believe here.
>> So it creates a new cloud code session
but human layer creates the human layer
session. So like it won't actually
create a human layer unless we unless we
create one. And I don't think we
necessarily want to show that because
this is just like a little one-off
throwaway session.
>> Yeah, exactly. And then it's going to be
recursive in problem.
>> Yeah. And this is actually a really
interesting, you do this with claw or by
hand, but it's really useful to have a
little proof of concept script before
you go into planning of like, hey,
here's an example of how I do this on
the shell. This is I know this works
kind of thing.
>> Do you want to read this?
>> Yeah, let's do it. Okay, cl go.
Okay, we add a new event type.
Go routine can be used in the session
manager after a session is created.
Yeah. See, this is a lot of
implementation details, which is
probably
>> I don't think it's a bad thing, though.
>> It's I will tell you why it's a bad
thing is like you don't want like you
want to brainstorm with the model. You
don't want the model to pick its first
choice because it's nondeterministic.
Like what gets much better results
especially for more complex things or
like when you have strong opinions about
the codebase and this happened in the
last stream where it was like do you
want to do this, this, or this? Okay,
for this part, do you want to do this,
this, or this? Hey, for this part, do
you want to do this, this, or this?
Maybe I should show you. When I was
doing this at least, it actually doesn't
often pick just one. It actually picks
like multiple options when it when I
when I ask it to go propose options
except for the areas where there's
really like one or two right choices.
>> But this is a plan. This is a plan. I'm
talking about research.
>> I'll take the research too. Sorry. The
research is very similar too.
>> Oh, sometimes it will propose options
here. Yeah. But like for example like
this research I worked on it for quite
some time and it actually generated like
multiple design like see
>> it actually just does that uh whenever
>> okay I have seen that sometimes um
>> where I go
>> all right cool let's go back to the yeah
synchronous oneoff sessions launch and
wait
session config options
okay cool this has uh these are the
fields we would choose.
Okay. All right. This is actually
probably going to be pretty good.
>> Yeah. Cool. That's what I figured.
>> Um,
>> cool. And because we haven't actually
tried this, I'm actually like when we go
to the planning, I would like one thing
in planning that I think is really
important is like put your biggest
unknowns as the first phase. And
>> Oh, you said added an SSC event, too.
>> Yeah. Well, it's it's it's proposing how
you could do this. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
Title change API
update session.
>> Does this look right?
>> Yeah, this looks pretty good. the um
yeah, one thing we'll add in the plan is
I'd like the query to be a little bit
viewshotted, which is like not just
here's the prompt, make a title, but
also here's the prompt and here's the
last 20 titles that the user put in. And
there's a difference in the system
between the like some sessions won't
have a user user selected title. Some of
them just use the prefix of the prompt,
but those are two separate columns in
the database. And so it's like I want to
grab the last 20 titles because if we
can make it follow their pattern, that's
going to be delightful.
>> But I think that's going to bias the
model in the wrong way because we're
going to have an AI generated title.
Where is that going to go? Is that in
the user generated title or the or the
>> So that's interesting. I think um yeah,
if the AI is going to generate a title,
uh a lot of people have already
developed systems for how they like to
manage their titles. I would say let's
plan to split that into separate phases
where it's like okay phase one or phase
n is going to be like just generate the
title and then phase n plus one will be
now try doing it with injecting the past
the past 20 titles and we can just play
with it at the end of each phase and see
how it feels.
>> Sorry, let me reframe the reframe the
thing. Um, what I meant that by that was
that if the user is generating the
title, what I'm worried about is going
to happen is that
>> how will you differentiate titles that
are generated by the AI model versus the
user?
>> We can add a new column for them. Yeah,
because at some point if the AI
generates a bad title, then you want to
go um Yeah, I think that's also worth
like that's that's a really good point.
Yeah, you're not getting that's why like
I think fuchsia prompting is actually
not going to work too well here
>> because it's not you won't know which
samples to actually use for fuchsia
unless you distinguish that in your
database somehow.
>> We should distinguish that in the
database though because if there's a
there's a if there's a AI generated
title and a user generated title I want
to I want to show the user title.
>> Cool. So shall we make a plan in that
case from this?
>> Uh yeah, let's make a new one. New new
session and we'll do create plan.
>> Uh okay. Do you need a new session?
We're pretty good on context. I think
it'll be fine.
>> Um
I think we should make a new session
>> into a plan. Okay, let's do that. Uh
I'll make a new plan for you. Uh this
one is still running.
Uh
>> yeah, can you just click into that one
and just can you title these properly?
>> Yes.
Research uh research uh what is this
called? Uh session titles with with
spec. This is like Yeah. Okay. And then
this is like research session titles. No
spec,
right? No. No. Like implementation that
we're trying to do.
>> Cool.
>> Uh and then I'm going to kick that off
while I before I go read the
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Plan.
>> So fire this off with nothing.
No, just No, with nothing in it. just
just create plan. Again, this is like a
trajectory thing. The reason why we do
this is because the thing that makes
planning really powerful is that it's a
back and forth conversation.
>> Uh and so you want to from day one set
the trajectory to there is user and
agent back and forth. If you just do
create plan and give it the research and
tell it what you want, it is much less
likely to follow the instructions of
like ask me questions then tell me the
outline only then write the file. And
the idea there is like you want to do as
much steering as possible before you eat
the like 8% of the context window that
is required to write out this 600 line
markdown document.
>> That's interesting. I have found it to
be much faster to not do it that way
because
>> depending on how complex it is, right?
It's like the the answer is like
depending on how hard and big the
feature is that it dictates the amount
of context engineering that you have to
do. The more context engineering you you
do, the the the the better the more
careful you are with guiding the
session, the bigger and more complex
features you can solve. And so the only
way to do this is to get a bunch of reps
and figure out like, okay, sometimes
you're going to use way too much context
engineering. It's going to feel like
overkill. Sometimes you're going to use
not enough context engineering and your
plan's going to suck and you're going to
have to go do a bunch of manual cleanup
on it. And the only way to know which
one is like right is just get a bunch of
reps and do it all the time.
I'm just skimming this really fast just
to make sure this is all correct. Um,
and what it's doing. I don't know this
codebase as well, so I just don't know
if it's picking up the right files.
That's up to you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
No, I think this is all fine.
We're we're simplifying a lot of this
architecture soon, so I haven't spent as
much time in this lately, but
Kyle's ripping out zoo stand and putting
in a proper like sync tanstack DV thing,
which I'm very excited about.
>> Yeah, when I look at this, I don't uh
>> No, this is fine. Keep scrolling and
I'll let you know if I see something.
Cool.
>> Yeah, this is probably fine.
>> Oh god. Actually this is this is useful.
Yeah. So this is more objective about
like how does the system work today
compared to the other one which is like
here's how it will work.
And the idea is like if you separate out
the like you want to keep the model
objective as long as possible because
it's very good at explaining what's
there. Models are very bad at evaluating
whether something is good or not. They
just want to tell us what we want to
hear. Right? We talked about this in the
like uh the email classification episode
too of like don't say scale of 1 to 10
how how bad is this. It's like give me a
bunch of boolean flags about like what
is true about this email and then I'll
use deterministic code to
>> is this good? Should I use this to
create the plan? What do I need to do
here?
>> So I think you I think you did you
already kicked off the plan, right? Or
you want to you like let's just use the
first one. I think the first one is
fine.
>> Oh well I I think we should run both
because then we can get an idea. um okay
about it
>> and then people can get an idea for like
exactly what the different processes end
up releasing because I think that's I
think a key part
>> okay so let's create another planning
session and and you give the other one
the other research but then I would say
the one with no spec so we made this we
made this research
>> we answer this one
>> so this is um can you which is this the
one with with spec or no spec no spec oh
this is with
>> this is the one with the spec this is
the one with no spec Yeah.
>> So this is see these questions are
objective. This is what these questions
are supposed to be which is like here's
the things I couldn't figure out by
reading the code. The other one is all
the questions are implementation
questions and you want to make sure the
model doesn't start thinking about how
to build it until it you you're
confident that it actually understands
how it works today. That's that's why we
try to keep the research objective.
>> So what should we do over here? [snorts]
>> Um I think most of these are probably
irrelevant. Um,
>> okay.
Time to gaslight.
>> Time to gaslight. [snorts]
>> Okay. Um, in that case, u I will even
>> So, you have your you have your planning
session.
>> So, yeah, let's do create plan. CL
create plan. Yeah,
>> create plan. And then I will put a path
as file. But you you prefer doing this.
>> I'm saying ship ship this and then go.
And there's the other thing you missed
on the last one, which is uh what I call
the magic words, which is like
reinforcing the instructions and the
like set of orders. Um, so before you
hit send on this, I'm going to give you
something else to add.
>> That's so interest. I feel like we vibe
code very very differently. Um,
>> well, I've learned as I've done this and
like worked with a lot of different
people on this, I found the things that
help like especially people who are
newer to this, I've found the things
that help keep this on track because
like I've done thousands of these at
this point. I have a very good sense of
like, oh, this thing skipped the
questions. That's bad. It needs to ask
the questions. But if you only done this
twice, you're not going to notice that
it's like skipping steps.
>> Yeah, I think even for like the way that
we code is very different on this, which
is just I think fascinating.
>> Um,
>> so this is objective. So in order to
actually get good results, we're going
to need to give it our spec, which is go
grab the prompt you used in the first
one, like the research session titles.
go like scroll to the top and just get
that first user message and copy it
>> the whole thing.
>> Yeah.
Yep.
Because Yeah. Because this one is is
actually what we're building. And so I
would tell it that and then before you
hit send Oh my god. You guys
>> just hit control X and we're going to
fork this.
>> Um wait till it actually emit. Yeah. Hit
control X. Uh hit command Y to fork.
Command enter. It's a funny Y bug.
>> Command enter. Yeah. No. What?
Command Y and then command enter.
And then at the end, you're going to put
something else. Put on the voice thing.
>> Yo. Okay.
>> Work back and forth with me starting
with your open questions and the phases
outline before you write the plan.
This is in the slash command. It's just,
you know, especially actually Opus 4.5.
Sometimes it follows instructions
better, but sometimes it skips steps.
Um, even Opus 4.1 would skip steps all
the time. So, okay. So, this is the Will
you just title this so we know which one
this is? So, this is the uh planning
session titles from research with spec.
So, key discoveries and then it's going
to have some questions.
I think those prompts are fine.
So I would just say like we're going to
write all the feedback in one message
and then send it all in one go. So you
can say one. Yes, that's fine.
Uh
silently fail and keep the default fall
back. That's great. Yeah, we can add
retries later.
Three
manual edit wins because we will always
show the manual the users manual thing
over the AI generated thing because
we're going to create a separate
the AI generated title should actually
be stored in a separate database column
that we'll have to create and in the UI
the manual edit will just generally win
because that column will take
precedence.
Perfect.
Always haiku for now. We can make it
configurable later.
>> Oh, unique.
>> Uh
well, which one do you want?
>> Yeah. Okay,
>> let's give this more bypass permissions
expire.
>> And then this is the planning session
titles. No spec, right?
This is the one we didn't give it a spec
during the research. Okay, cool. Those
are running. You want to jump to
Obsidian?
>> Do it.
>> Okay, cool.
And this one is is small. So I'm fine if
if the research is low quality because
it has like specification in it. Uh
that's that's fine because there's
pretty much only one way to do this
thing. There's not a lot of like
brainstorming that needs to happen.
Um yes, the app name helpers are
correct. The existence validation looks
good.
Um
preference stuff. Yeah, this looks
correct.
Settings dialogue. Yep. Um, file link,
use file shortcuts, active session,
additional directories. Yeah, those are
all fine.
>> I mean, I don't even know how to open a
file in Obsidian.
>> Um, I think I mean we can try it on the
CLI, but um, can you just find like what
folder is your Obsidian in?
>> Research
to open a file via a CLI command from
Obsidian.
>> I think we just use Yeah. And uh
>> I don't I don't know if Obsidian allows
this because Obsidian I don't think
allows for opening files.
>> Yeah,
>> but you can't open
>> I am pretty sure. So yeah, we need to
figure this out. Yeah.
>> Yeah, that's my point. So like we'll
just let this run.
Um and I think that's the one thing I
didn't see in the research right away. I
was like I did not see anything related
to opening a file in Obsidian.
>> Yeah. And this is where I get into like
PC's like if you can get the bash
oneliner to open a file in Obsidian
that's great guidance like and prove
that it works to yourself. This is a
thing that's like not really baked into
the methodology yet but is like the
value of like doing little one-off tests
as part of your research. Today research
is like search the web and search the
codebase as it exists. that there's not
a stage in here that is more around um
that is as much around uh what is it
like reverse engineer a blackbox system
where we don't have the code for it. Um
we do this a lot with like the cloud
code CLI. All right, cool.
>> Should we generate titles for draft
sessions? Drafts might not have a
>> No, do it on launch.
Two. Sure. Three. Draft session handling
only on launch. I kind of like the idea
of drafts having them too. But that's
okay.
>> That's later. Yeah. The problem is with
the draft thing is that if people don't
know that it's autotitled and they just
always make a title for all their
sessions, then they're never going to
see this feature. But we couldn't kind
of like this is all this is all stuff
where I'm like I really want to just get
this working as quickly as possible and
then we can go back and iterate on the
UI a little bit.
I also um one thing I will say is like
putting just option B and not like a
tiny summary of like what it actually is
is like put more is going to put more
load on the model's like attention. Um
so for five I would say like small
spinner.
>> Yeah. Especially for like a complex
thing where there's a lot of options.
>> I find it to be
>> um
>> that's been pretty good at this for you.
Okay.
>> It just depends. Um I think what I
>> it depends but you like the problem is
what I don't want is like it goes and
writes the plan and then you're like
[__] it didn't follow my instructions
like this
>> in my opinion like um
uh no uh
the AI generator title should be saved
in a separate database column and
therefore whenever the user edits it
they're adding a second database column
and we can guarantee that the user title
will always win no matter what.
Seven. Yeah, just keep the inherited
title. That's fine.
>> Cool.
And then I would um again do like tell
me the phases I Okay. I would say tell
me the phases outline before you write
the plan because sometimes it skips that
step and that's like part of what makes
this so powerful.
>> Okay, so let's try this.
Um
>> oh
yeah, actually everyone in the chat is
also sending links to how to do this.
>> Oh, does it work?
>> If this works, this is this is going to
change my uh workflow a lot.
users.
>> I don't think your shell autocomplete is
going to work here.
>> I think you probably need a triple
slash.
>> Yeah, I'll just add that in.
>> Nice. Can you open a directory with
that?
Um um let me close
>> Can you Can you do one that's not Yeah.
Can you just do like a file on your
desktop or something that's not already
open? Cool.
>> Um I don't think it opened it.
>> All right, let's try again.
>> Uh and this is just like making sure
that this actually works. All right, so
this definitely works because it's
already in my thoughts.
a separate thing.
>> So yeah, this so then we will use like
in the planning we're going to use like
the tower plugin opener.
>> I'm just going to assume that this
works.
>> TildaVbV just do tilda repreos.
>> Oh yeah, I can do that.
>> Yeah. So I need to have a vault already
made in order for it to open it.
>> Okay. But that's usually like
>> I should have one.
>> You're gonna have that.
>> Yeah. Cool.
>> Um but we do need to handle that error.
>> And we can always do a follow on
feature, right? Like this is still you
universally adds value and then later
you can add another feature that it's
like make the vault if it doesn't exist.
>> Yes.
Uh path is here third party. Nope. We
don't want that. We want method one.
>> Yep.
>> Oh, the other one is a tower plugin. I
think, right?
>> Um,
app.opener. Yeah, app.opener is actually
probably the best one.
>> App.opener
is the best one.
>> So, we're going to tell it to like
include that in the research.
>> Yep. Tell do that. Now, we can go read
this one.
>> Okay. So, here's our phases.
Ah,
>> let's go back to obsidian. Let's read
this one. I'm not going to
So it's it's still it's still proposing
the phases. So it hasn't written a file
yet.
>> Did it write a file?
>> It did. Yeah.
>> See, this is the thing is you really
want to iterate on the phases before you
go write the file. Um because now you've
used a ton of your context window and
you're either in the dumb zone or you
need to go rebuild all that context when
you want to iterate on this plan.
>> The idea of having it talk through the
phases with you is for it to outline the
phases. still has a ton of meaning, but
it's only a couple hundred tokens versus
writing this plan as thousands of tokens
and now you've like exhausted a lot of
the like useful part of the context
window.
>> But the question I have for that is does
that matter for a phase where the phases
are correct? Cuz I can just go back.
>> No, if everything is correct is is good,
but I guarantee you that this is wrong.
>> Uh let's take a look. Let's see if I can
>> because it's not.
>> So schema update is fine, but it's it's
not. So the thing is I want to get the
unknowns out of the way as quickly as
possible which means that I want to get
the like a standalone endpoint to test
the haiku call and make sure it can pull
from all this stuff before we update the
database schema. See this is what the
models always want to do and we need to
update our create plan prompt to fix
this better. They're very horizontal.
They're like do everything in the
database then create the service class
with no like entry point that I can
access it and then update open API. So
like by the end of phase three is the
only time you'll even be able to like
run a curl command to validate anything.
And by that time you're going to have
hundreds of lines of code. And if it's
wrong, you're like stuck. And so I
really actually what I will say is like
I want to fork this session and have it
create a new plan and tell it what the
phases should be.
>> Interesting. But so help me understand
what's wrong with this plan. So like
just
>> so the problem with this plan is like
you're going to do the database schema
update which I think that's fine that
can be phase one but then it's going to
generate a title generator service which
there is no way to test that. This is
the most like critical part of this and
>> well I can write a unit test in go that
test that function.
>> No you can't write a unit test because
it involves invoking the cloud code.
It's I mean it's an integration test
basically.
>> Yeah that's fine.
Um, so I mean, yeah, we can iterate on
this plan in place.
>> It's going to create one function and
then I can test that function though.
>> No, it's going to create the function
and then it's going to wire it in and
it's going to add all this stuff. And I
guess my thought is like
>> but
>> I want to you want to split your phases
up into things that can be individually
and like where it matters like manually
verified beyond just reading the code.
You want to be able to run a shell
command or run a really like read a
really good like integration test and
make sure it's doing what you want.
because otherwise you're just stuck
reading the code and like your goal is
leverage. You want to be able to have
the AI write the code and as long as the
code is like clean enough for you, you
don't want to have to go read the logic
and make sure it's correct. You want to
be able to be like, "Yep, I hit a I hit
that endpoint with a curl and it works."
>> So,
>> and I'm ready to proceed.
>> The question I have for you is what I
want to do here is like fundamentally
you're not going to be able to hit this
endpoint with a curl because it's doing
a background process. So I mean what you
can do is you can just build the service
and hook it up to a endpoint and then
reuse the same service elsewhere but
like I want to be able to validate it in
a running process.
>> I agree. But do you not think that we
can just like test this? Like we can
test the generate method and make sure
it does something sane.
So yeah, I the the fastest way and
probably the thing you'll like the best
is probably like, hey, add an
integration test to phase 2 that
actually doesn't mock anything, actually
invokes the cloud SDK and just runs the
service as part of a test.
>> It like uses my anthropic use actually
it doesn't even use your anthropic API
key because we want to make sure it
inherits your cloudmax subscription.
>> Yes, but that I think would work.
Correct.
>> Yeah. So let's let's give it feedback
like the first bit of feedback is uh
need some testing so I can actually make
sure that the stuff is working
correctly.
>> What's Maybe I'm confused. What's the
thing that you're specifically looking
to test in phase 2?
>> I want to make sure that this function
actually like launches the Cloud Code
CLI and like builds the thing properly
and like and like actually like I want
to be able to put in what's 2 plus two
and get an answer back or I want to be
able to like make sure that the part
where it's like here's the user's
prompt, give me a title. I want to make
sure that's working.
Well, integrated with like the cloud
stuff. I want to do an integration test
here.
>> We I shouldn't tell you that. I should
have just told the model that, but
[snorts]
>> even more so true. But what I'm trying
to figure out here is like when I go
look into this, like
>> I can just generate this async and then
this will do the trick. But I can just
go generate.
>> You don't want to be reviewing the code
for correctness because then you're not
getting much leverage. you're just using
all the same mental space, but you're
not editing it in an editor. You're
editing it in markdown. And that's
actually like less good than just
writing the code in an editor. So, you
want a very easy way to convince
yourself that the code itself is
correct. And that could be an
integration test. It could be a shell
script. It could be like a one-off go
program with its own main function.
Like, I don't care what it is, but like
I wouldn't feel good about this plan
because we're just going to rip through
to the very end and like see if it
works. And I don't I don't like that
because I want to be able to actually
like
>> validate along the way so that if
something is broken, I'm only working
with a couple a hundred or a couple
hundred lines of code rather than trying
to debug a thousand lines of code cuz
that just [__] sucks.
>> But what's going to be broken here?
Maybe maybe I'm confused.
>> I don't know. I don't know what's going
to be broken, but I know that if you
can't validate it until the end of step
four, then like you're it's more likely
to I'm it's like how do I get leverage
over over the model?
I I can see that perspective. I think
what I have found at least when I vibe
code is I actually do read the code that
it snips out because I find it
>> no you do you should read the code but
also like
>> I think that it's faster and like the
thing that makes models like models are
not good at evaluating whether code is
correct. Yep.
>> So, you want a thing that you can valid
validate is correct, which is like if
you're just going to read every single
line of code and try to mentally model
the whole thing. Like I'm telling you
that my plan my my my approach here
would be add unit. So, I don't want unit
tests. I want full integration tests
that actually invoke the cloud CLI.
>> Is this not what this does?
>> It says unit tests.
>> Uh I think it's just trying a bunch of
inputs. Let's go look at the No, because
this is about publishing events. This is
about the integration into the demon. I
just want to make sure that our code
that like invokes claude is correct. Let
me add the test.
>> So, it's it says it's adding a test. It
said it added test. We can go read what
the tests are, but I guarantee it's
going to like mock the things that we
care about.
>> Blah blah blah phase two.
>> So, it's in 2.5.
>> Yeah.
Are you worried that the cloud prompt is
going to fail or the parameters for the
cloud prompt are cloud CLI are wrong?
>> I'm worried that there's like seven
layers of call stack to wire this
through correctly. And I'm looking for
an easier way to tell if that's correct
um
than to read every line of code or to
wait till we get to the very end and be
like, "Oh, it's [__] broken." And I
have no idea where cuz we just changed
hundreds and hundreds of lines of code.
>> Do these unit tests look correct to you?
Do these look useful?
>> I don't see anywhere.
>> No, these don't look useful.
>> Okay,
>> keep going
>> cuz I think this is going to trigger the
bus and you're looking to see that
sessions are generated for all of them.
I'm not I'm not interested in the like
there's two things that I want to test
and if they're complexed then it's going
to be really hard to figure out which
one of them is broken. One of them is
like are we sending the right things to
Claude? Are we correctly overwriting the
system prompt? Are we setting the model
correctly? Are we wiring that through?
And the other part is like the demon
getting that back publishing to the
event bus and doing all this like all of
that should not be in one phase and it
should be like those two things should
be independently testable.
>> I see. You just want to break phase two
into two separate things. One is like
calling Claude and one is hooking it up
to the Damon. That's I mean that's part
of it, but like the I that's the what
and the how, but the why is the thing I
want to like drill in here, which is
that like we need to be able to
>> um validate this before we add like we
cannot if we add like a bunch of
complexity in one set of and maybe
that's just like because of the some of
the complexities in the architecture of
this system like I know from working in
this codebase that it's going to be I
mean we can just go it's also like this
The other thing that I say is like don't
obsess too much over getting the plan
100% right. Like if the logic is wrong,
that's fine. You just want it right
enough that you can like if you get to
the end of the phase, you'll have enough
context and enough it'll be close enough
that you can like vibe out the end of
it.
>> That's kind of what I was thinking. It
looks like this thing looks right enough
to me and like I think models are
getting better. Like the new cloud model
is probably pretty good.
So like the previous assumptions we held
might not be as true anymore.
>> But I
like what we can do I think is just
launch this see if it generates tests.
If it generates tests and it all launch
it in a work tree and while it's running
I'm I really want to go create a new
version of this plan because I don't
like this plan. I wouldn't implement
this plan. I would throw this out and
start over.
>> Okay, then let's do that.
>> All right. So uh yeah, let's do go back
to that's fine.
No, not this one. Go back to before it
wrote the plan.
>> Uh, command Y.
>> So, yeah. Yeah, that one.
Um, cool. Uh, and then just, um, tell me
the Yeah, show me the phases outline
before you write the plan. I want to
here. Can I can I talk?
>> Go ahead.
>> I want to be able to validate early on
that the integration with the cloud CLI
and the Haiku model is working. So we
will need one phase to make the cloud
code go changes and have an integration
test in that v phase that shows me that
that part is working. From there we can
go to adding phase two we can add the
database column and then in phase three
we will wire in the go routine into the
event bus and publishing. Um but
actually phase three should just fire
off the go routine and write the result
to the database and we'll verify that
manually like with a command uh just to
check the SQLite and then in phase four
we will wire up the SSC and event bus
stuff to make sure that the front end is
notified and then in phase five then we
can we can actually like catch the event
on the front end and do something with
it.
This is how I would build this. This is
optimized for being able to verify that
the parts of it like we have very strong
opinions about how this should be built
now after reading through it and talking
about it. I want to build this the way
that I would build this as an engineer
which is like that's the order I would
go in because that's how you like kind
of like consolidate all your
>> I feel like you're not leveraging the
model as much.
>> Uh you cannot outsource the thinking
man. And I mean that's the thing I've
learned in working in complex systems is
like if you don't come with opinions the
model will not I mean you could ask the
model to do that but like if you know
what you want just tell the model what
you want. That's my advice. I mean you
could see if the model could get there
but it's the same thing with 12 factor
agents right? Like if you know what the
[__] workflow is that you want just
make that in deterministic code and then
let the model do what the model is good
at which is like writing correct code
writing tests running the tests and
fixing it.
>> So check out what it's doing now. It's
using anthropic API key.
Yeah, that's uh so
um phase one doesn't need anthropic API
key. We need to test that the invocation
of the cloud code will uh use the user's
cloud code max plan.
>> Oh, you might um try it.
>> All right, try it again.
Read phase two meanwhile.
Yeah, this is great. We can go to phase
two. Uh that's uh sorry. Uh
that that's not good enough.
Uh no, your phase one is not is not
enough.
Uh we want to make sure that um we are
using the user's claude code max
subscription when invoking the haiku
call.
Fine. Uh okay. Go routine integration.
Yeah. Phase three looks good.
Phase four looks good.
Uh yeah, I think this is good. Again,
like I'm not going to micromanage this.
This took the plan for me from like 70%
to 90%. And 90% for me is good enough.
And like this is the other thing that
like I'm always advising people is
people like this takes so [__] long.
I'm spending an hour reading the plan.
It's like, okay, one is as you get reps,
you'll you'll learn to you'll learn what
good looks like.
Um,
yeah, this looks fine.
>> That's incorrect, right? You don't
actually want to use the CLI. You want
to use the routine thing that you have,
the manager thing that you have.
>> No, no, no, no. Um,
so
no, that's good because cloud code go is
just invoking the cloud CLI off your
like system path.
All right.
This is the one without spec that we had
from earlier.
>> Yeah, I I'm I'm I'm happy to throw this
one out. I think the other one is good
enough.
>> Um
>> Oh, I like that. This Yeah, the other
thing we could have done is like test
the event stream wiring and just have it
like do a mock event and show it in the
front end and get the front end right.
That's another like tactic that I think
that's really useful is like figure out
the contract between the front end and
the back end and figure out a way to
like mock the backend side and get the
front end right and then go implement
the back end
>> because when you know the front end is
right and you know the contract is
connected correctly then you have a
visual way to debug.
>> I'm going to spin up a great
>> create plan.
>> You going to do it in the same session?
>> I am. I think you're actually wrong on
how much context you can use personally.
Like I'm not saying it's like always
true, but I do think that for a lot of
things it's actually quite you I think
people can push the context windows
further than they think.
Especially
>> Yeah. But also you're the guy who told
me that you don't do as much coding in
in code layer because you don't really
trust the plans and the execution of the
plans. And I'm like maybe that's a side
effect of the fact that you're
constantly pushing the context window to
70%.
>> Well, that's not what I mean. I do use
code for more complicated features.
Actually, I use it for most of the
complicated features, but for simpler
features, I found it to be like uh too
much.
>> Jump a cursor and do it in 15 minutes.
>> It just Yeah, exactly. It's just like
context switching. It's actually not
about like not using it, just like
what's the app I have open. That's the
one I use.
>> That's actually code.
>> You've been working in your codebase in
cursor for over a year now. And I have
pretty much only worked in this codebase
using using clot and code layer. Um, but
I think what I'm trying to say is like
for me it's more about context switching
over anything else. And like when I have
like a really complicated research
pipeline to do, then I love using code
layer. It's amazing for that.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, there we go.
>> Okay, we got a plan. Let's uh let's peep
it.
>> There. Look.
>> Oh, did it overwrite the other one?
>> I deleted it.
>> Ah, okay. Cool.
>> Smart.
>> Yes, because again, I'm not going to
make the model do that.
>> Cool.
Okay.
Okay. We make attempter.
>> I don't think this prompt is going to
work every single time, but that's okay.
That's separate.
>> Yeah, we can go we can come back and fix
the prompt. I actually was thinking we
should have it do JSONish and then pull
in the BAML parser or at the very least
like do XML tags and like string
splitting.
>> Yeah, we can try a few different things.
Cool. Does this look right to you?
>> Um, yeah, this looks great.
>> Cool.
>> This is good enough to test and then
we'll we'll try it and then uh Okay. And
then add integration test. Yeah, let's
kick it off and tell it to just do phase
one.
>> Um, don't you want to read all of it
first?
>> Uh, no. So, this is the thing we did
last time, too, which I think is great
is like if phase one is good, kick it
off and then we'll come back and read
phase two. So, we'll just kick it off
and say just do phase one. And there's a
new command I'm going to show you as
well which we're rolling into the
product system which is like
>> this is not going to work very well
because
>> yeah make make a new session.
>> Oh yeah. Uh have it make a work tree for
the work. Do you have cloud instructions
for work trees?
>> No, we'll find out. Um
>> oh that'll work.
Uh well, you want to create a you'll
have to create a new session in the work
tree to do the implementation.
>> Uh I'm going to let this run really fast
once it makes a work tree.
>> Yeah.
>> And then I'll hit control X.
Okay, let's see.
Tell it to run the script with the no
thoughts flag
and uh don't do a human layer launch.
Just make the work tree.
>> Let's see what else it does.
>> Cuz this is going to launch it to do the
full implementation. And actually like
this part of this command is like very
alpha
>> which is why we're like resteering it a
lot.
>> And the war is rid of it. Okay. So I
have war tree.
>> Okay. It's going to go do the setup.
Yeah, it tries to copy yourcloud
settings local and if you don't have
one, that part's probably going to fail.
>> I see.
>> But now it's going to go do the setup.
And then yeah, you can make a new
session in that work tree and tell it to
start implementing.
>> Cool. And how do I tell it to use that
work tree?
>> So you it's just um yeah, hit C.
Yeah. So just hit make a new code layer
session and in that directory let me
copy and paste this.
>> Yep. And then do slashphased implement.
This is a new one. We moved all our
implementation to sub agents. Uh this is
a cool thing we'll be rolling out soon.
Yep.
thoughts, [snorts] shared plans.
Boom. Ship it.
>> Interesting. Did you use phase
implement? I have found that the model
once it does the testing, I don't need
to actually go validate anything.
>> Well, so here's what's cool is with
phased implement, it launches a sub
agent to do the work. The sub agent does
the testing and validation and then
reports to the parent model and the
parent model also checks it and then
asks you for for manual validation.
All
right, [snorts] let's look at the
Obsidian thing. Well, so also I want to
try to like focus on one thing at a
time. So, we just launched phase one of
that one, and we need to review the rest
of the plan. Yeah, you can answer this,
too.
>> Wait, well, you're saying yes, but it's
giving you two options.
>> It wants to make No, I'm answering these
questions.
>> Uh oh. Here, let me see what it does.
>> No, just add obsidian to the existing
editor list. Wait, why?
>> Because I don't want to add another type
of setting that is markdown editor.
>> But how are you going to open code
files?
>> All right, fine.
>> Cool.
I think the [laughter] the thing it's
saying is actually correct.
>> Yeah, I guess it makes sense.
Like it's not even like it's not an
incorrect choice, right? Like you do
need a secondary setting for this where
it's like it's just
>> Yeah. Okay. And they can be the same
thing. Like the the one thing I want to
make sure is that the markdown editor
like that it has all the same options.
>> Well, we'll just read the plan and we'll
see what it does.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. Cool. So, it did say the
code editors handle both code and
markdown. So, that they should all be in
the list.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah. The Obsidian URI requires
file files to be in a vault. I'm
curious. I'm going to test something
real quick with just like if you do
open- a obsidian and give it a path to a
file that's not in a vault.
>> Oh, your phase implement has like a sub
agent that does stuff.
>> It does the the Yes. All the
implementation instructions are in a sub
agent. So this way you can actually do
all the phases in one session.
>> Yeah.
>> This worked for me. I'm going to just
put this in the in the chat here in the
public chat. But if you just do open and
give it a directory, you can actually
have you can do Obsidian
uh without needing to
>> really. Are you sure you don't accident?
>> Let me try again. Let me make sure it
actually worked.
Let me send it.
>> Yeah, that just works if you give it a
path. So, we can actually maybe we don't
want to use the Obsidian URL and we just
want to use open- a, which is what all
the other editor opens use
because then you don't need a vault in
there.
Yeah, try that.
Nope.
>> Give it a sec.
No chance.
>> It's probably just really big. Use a
smaller thing. You have a [__] ton of
rep. Yeah, there you go.
>> No, then it just opens.
>> Uh, give it a smaller repo. Give
[snorts] it like just your thoughts
repo.
>> Um, well, I already have a thing on
there. I can do like um I can do like
AI.
>> Yeah. See,
>> it doesn't open it.
>> What version of Obsidian do you have?
Mine just did this perfectly.
Maybe I already had one in there.
>> Yeah, you can't run it that way.
I I mean, it makes sense. Obsidian works
off of vaults for everything.
>> Okay. All right, fine. We'll just
require a vault. We can figure that out
later.
>> Cool.
Running this.
Lots of good conversation in the chat.
>> What do we have? Add uh Yeah, I'm not
seeing the chat at all while I'm working
today.
>> Yep. Backend preferences
UI components settings UI. Yeah, that's
fine.
>> Are these good scopes?
>> Yeah, that's fine. Yeah, this one also
like isn't really like eminently like us
unit testable. So, we can just ship this
or there's not a lot of like if there's
testing patterns in place, it'll add
them. But otherwise, I don't want to
force it to write tests because parts of
this are just like kind of plumbed
through.
So, it built some test cases and then it
has this. So, do you want me to go open
this? How do I open this file? Why
wouldn't it open?
>> Uh, you can only open We're getting
there. Uh, this is another AI feature
you could do is just detect file paths
and add links to them. But we only um
Yeah. Um, so if you scroll up to the
write call, yeah, it only works on like
edit and write call basically like tool
calls where like one of the JSON fields
is a file path and we know that it is.
>> I see.
>> Um, but it looks like it ran our test.
So, um, I would be interested to read
that test and like see that it's passing
because that's kind of how I do this.
Like, okay, if the integration test
passes, then I don't have to worry too
much about the You need to set your
default editor.
>> Go into settings
uh, at the bottom.
Yeah, there you go.
Uh, yeah, set your default editor to
whatever you want to use. Yeah, there
you go.
Oh, I didn't know what. Okay.
>> Yeah. Cool. Okay. So, what is this
actually going to do? Client.generate
title. Can you click into client
gengenerate title?
>> Well, we can just look at the results,
right?
I Well, I just want to make sure that
that's the right function.
Yeah, this is the one we wrote. Okay,
cool. Um, sick. Okay. And uh let's yeah,
let's look at the test cases.
Query generated title. And it's just
doing basic sanity checks. Uh, so let's
go look at the test output and look at
the logs because it's it's just logging
the stuff and then doing like a sanity
check.
>> Where's the test output?
>> So if you go into the code layer
session, you can see where it ran that
test.
Nice.
All right. Yeah, this looks pretty good.
Okay. This was one of the bigger
unknowns for me. So, I'm glad we got
this working. Let's uh let's tell it
we're good and we can proceed to phase
two.
>> Okay, cool.
>> It's just did it in tail. So,
>> phase two.
>> Yep. Let's do it. Yeah, because we can
always come back and mess with the
prompting. Um, I just want to make sure
this is wired all the way through. This
is again, this is like vertical slices.
Get it like you should be sprinting to
as quickly as possible get to wired all
the way through. [snorts]
>> That's interesting. I think I
It's interesting. We develop it very
differently, I think, in our repos.
>> Yeah. Well, this is why we we hang out
and swap ideas and learn things from
each other. That's the goal of the show,
right? Yeah. Uh what we end up doing is
we actually just focus on building a
really good test harness where we can
add more tests incrementally.
>> Yeah.
>> And then just focus on um getting each
layer perfectly correct and then work
through the to the end.
>> Yeah, that's what I found to be red
green refactor iterate right.
>> TDD.
>> Yeah,
>> red green. Sorry, I don't know what that
is. TDD is like you write the red test
and then you make it green and then you
refactor it and you keep it green.
>> Yeah, exactly. And then I found well
I've also found like in general like
just for example like making it work
from like the very back end layer is at
least in our repo it's very hard to make
it work all the way end to end and just
get something plumbed all the way
through.
>> Yeah.
>> So we just try and make it so that uh
the right data
>> is present as much as possible in each
layer and then just test each layer
individually.
>> Yep. Um, okay, cool. Let's just scroll
down. This looks fine. Obsidian open
path equals. That's what we were doing.
I don't think that's right. I think the
format was just
>> It just requires you to have a vault.
That's all it is. That's a URI.
>> No, but wasn't the command you were
running was very different.
>> No,
>> go in your terminal. You were opening
obsidian and it's just the path.
Uh,
we also have the app thing that we were
doing before, right?
I would just give it that feedback.
I don't know if that also works. I mean,
you could try it, but
also where'd it go?
>> What is it called?
Also, we want to use appetite opener.
Oh, this is this we told it to do this.
>> Well, it it decided that that's that's
the thing. I don't know if it
hallucinated this or if this also works.
You can try we can test it if you go to
the your terminal. Just try just try
doing the open with that with that um
path.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> So, it's open question mark path equals
>> Yeah, it is.
>> Okay, don't worry.
>> That's fine. All right, we'll do that.
Uh, cool. So, let's keep reading the
plan then.
Cool.
Uh, updating file link.
Uh,
>> there's nothing else with the markdown
file.
>> Wait a minute. Scroll down.
>> Yeah, this is wrong because it's like it
should be open in. So, so look at how it
does the editor stuff
>> where.
>> So, scroll down a little bit. So, editor
is get preferred editor.
>> Yeah. Y
>> and then it does invoke open in editor
with the path and the editor.
>> The other one if you scroll up it's
calling a special function called open
in no uh down
like literally in that same function
like five lines up it's doing get
preferred markdown editor and then it's
like if the markdown file is this and
the markdown editor is obsidian then we
do open in obsidian.
Uh oh I see. Okay. It's trying to be
clever. I mean, this code is ugly, but
it's technically like slightly less code
to write because it's just doing if it's
Obsidian, then we just open in Obsidian.
Otherwise, we fall through and open it
in your editor.
>> Yep.
>> I'm fine with this. It's not beautiful,
but it's I'm
>> What do you want to do?
>> Uh, propose alternative.
>> Uh, I was thinking that it would like
match. There's basically like we always
calling open in editor and the rust side
of it because this is calling like
invoking a rust function from the front
end. I would prefer if open and editor
just handles like the markdown logic on
the back end.
>> Okay, let's just do that. That I mean
that's the good thing about vibe coding.
It's not hurting my feelings, right?
Like model doesn't care.
>> Yeah. Um Yeah. I So it's like I'd prefer
if the markdown splitting happens in
>> I'd prefer if the markdown splitting was
happening in the open and editor
capability rather than in the logic
ahead of uh in front of this function
for this function.
Yes.
Cool. All right. Let's keep reading
while it's fixing that.
I personally take everything my model
does personally. [laughter]
Um, okay.
Yeah, because then we have that that
block duplicated in this function too,
which is annoying.
Um, oh, then settings UI.
Did we add a database column for
this setting or is it just in local
storage? Oh, I think it's cuz the
preferred editor is in local storage.
It's not in the It's not in the It's not
in the database.
All right, fine. Just leave it as is.
Um,
this one's still implementing phase two.
Let's go back to the Obsidian one. I
Let's just keep this how it is. That's
fine. We I will go back and refactor
this to use settings later.
>> I think it should be really easy for it
to do. Oh, because you need the
database.
>> Oh, no, no, no. It can just fetch it and
then send it in the endpoint. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. We just send them
both. Open an editor has a new thing
called markdown editor. Yeah, that's
much better.
>> [__] yeah. Okay, cool. Yeah, this is
going to work.
>> Cool.
Let's go read this.
>> Um,
cool. We already read this. Yeah, we've
been through this. It made a whole new
thing.
>> Uh, okay. Cool.
>> It It updated. You can't skip.
>> Okay. So, it takes editor and markdown
editor. Yep. Okay. So, he's markdown,
>> right? Then it has a way for obsidian.
Otherwise, it just does it that way.
>> Yeah. I'm okay. This could be factored a
little more nicely, but I'm I'm I'm
happy with this. This keeps all that
like logic like kind of isolated to one
place that's testable.
>> Cool. Should I do it?
>> Yeah, let's let it rip.
>> Okay. I don't think we need phase
[snorts] implementation for this. I'm
just going to
>> do phased implementation. It's just
better. You just want to give yourself
>> It's be It's the same reason why you use
a bigger model even though you might
want to use a smaller one.
CL implement plan.
>> Fine. [snorts]
>> Just trust me.
>> All right.
Vibes.
I trust you, buddy.
>> The I think a lot of what a lot of
people underestimate is just like, like
I said, this is something I say a lot
like a lot of people start locking in
their perspective of model way too fast.
>> Yeah. You got to you got to binary
search on either side and like try
things that you really think won't work
and see because that's how you learn
what the boundaries are. I I suspect
that you're like, "Hey, we need phase
implementation." Like looking at this,
I'm like, "No, you probably don't." Like
I my personal opinion says like, "And
even if I don't, worst case, I waste
like five minutes or a couple with a
thousand tokens. I just redo it."
>> Phase implement you can just tell it
like, "Do every single phase in a row.
Don't wait for my input." And all that's
the only difference is you're doing the
exact same work, but you're using
smaller context windows to do the work.
>> Uh, you're in the work tree, dude.
Oh [__]
>> Yeah. Um, so you'll have to go do that
work tree thing again or go to the one
where you made the work tree and be
like, make another one for this thing.
>> No, I'm just not going to do the work
tree.
>> All right. You're so confident.
>> Um, I think this is the other thing that
I really want like in any coding editor.
I want it to detect when I'm making
mistakes like that to be honest.
>> Yep. No, I mean that's that's uh
>> like that's what actually makes this
stuff really good. like this like part
of
>> well I mean giving you a first class
like you hit command K implement and it
like looks at the plan and figures out
what it should be and like having the
stuff organized into tests and projects
is a big part of that too. One of the
things I would push back on on that is
like I think while that is kind of
interesting, what I really want is just
like I just want to catch mistakes for
me
>> and like if it's the more opinion it is
and how I do my work, the harder it is
as a edi as a developer to really abide
by it 100% of the time because as a
developer
>> that's the trade-off. There's there's
other tools that like really do all the
work tree [__] for you, but they also
bring a lot of opinions, which like I
for me some of some some of my like
friction there was like I don't like how
opinionated this is and I want something
a little more like I want to be able to
decompose it like and the goal is like
first experience it does it all for you
but then you can decompose it into
building blocks and get more flexibility
as you grow
>> kind of. So maybe I can show you a
couple things that at least I'll show
you that I have found interesting now.
So like what I have found is like this
tool is freaking dumb to be honest. But
like whenever I actually create a plan
now what I actually do is I'll show you
exactly what I do. Um like let's say I
was doing uh
>> this is read your quad commands now.
>> Yeah.
>> I see.
>> Exactly. Um but I'll show you like
exactly what I would have done from
scratch if I were doing this. Uh like
what I actually do is whenever I create
plans I actually do this uh cl
like research codebase I'd say something
like um figure out how I can add AI
generated summaries
and I just like swap it on like this
and this has been um
>> Oh and then you do like four in
parallel.
>> Exactly.
And I don't even care. Just go read at
the end because it's just saving me a
bunch of time, right? Like um and this
GPT codeex is so dumb. I hate codeex.
Um and now that it's doing this, it
doesn't really even matter what model
I'm using to be honest because I don't
I'm not tied to a model. I'm not tied to
anything else. But like the ability to
like multiplex is super useful. And what
I have found at least for a lot of our
code bases is rather than focus on
getting this one prompt really right,
what I let it do is I let like three or
four models produce similar uh similar
outputs and then based on what the
models produce cuz it's way faster than
me going down to this is
then what I do is I just read this thing
and this I hate so I actually end up
reading this in Obsidian.
Uh and the way I do that is I have to do
some stupid process of like syncing this
back. So, what do I have to do? I have
to like accept this thing.
Where do I go?
>> Yeah, this is the funny thing, too, is
like
>> it's uh the like cursor UX is for for
like code changes that matter versus
like if you're just dumping a markdown
doc like we don't use work trees for
that. We don't really feel that you need
like it's just like you're you're doing
it's like a write only like single.
>> The minute I start doing stuff in
parallel, it's actually super useful.
to have if you're editing code, but if
you're just dumping out new research
documents, I'm like, I don't know if
super useful. And the reason that it
ends up being super useful even in that
scenario is because
>> you just
>> is because it will end up over if I have
like two parallel things. Sometimes
it'll end up overwriting each other with
the same name that it generates for the
thought for the research that it
produces.
>> Oh yeah, that's bad. I mean, that's why
you would want Yeah.
>> work trees. It's more about when I'm
multipplexing, right? cuz that's really
the problem when I end up doing things.
It's easy to have like a single work
work experience and like that is the
only reason I actually found like it was
kind of interesting with multipplexing
for like really really complex things
cuz there's just no way.
Uh
how do I do this? Okay, I'll just try
this. Why not?
>> Yeah. So, you have to so you have to go
take your running version and actually
go like check that out. This is wrong. I
will give you the this is the other
thing is like we read the plans but we
didn't actually this is the thing
everybody does including myself is you
like forget to check the like actual
testing steps uh but I can just help you
do this. So uh you have sync layer
running somewhere. So what you want to
do is you want to create a new session
and then go make sure that it wrote the
new title to the database.
Yeah, there we go.
>> So I'll run this.
>> Yep.
Yeah, the multiplexing has been super
clutch. I really am excited for when you
add that in because I think it'll be
super nice to be able to just be
>> talking about multiplexing. You mean
like being able to launch multiple
sessions with different models?
>> Different models and then be able to
merge them trivially.
>> I like that. Cool.
>> Yeah, it's really like in this case like
see in this case it's not too bad.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh where is this? Okay, so this the
thing and
>> so I'm going to I'm going to show you a
couple things. Number one, you're not
going to run that command again. You're
not going to run that. So, uh, at the
bottom there, click on the debug, uh,
button. Yeah, that one. That's going to
tell you your database path. Uh, yeah.
Okay. So, at the bottom there, there's a
path to your database in the bottom.
Uh, debug information path. Yeah. So,
you're going to you're going to use that
as the path instead
into SQLite 3.
I actually have no one ones today
because technically I'm on vacation.
>> Nice. What better way to spend your
vacation?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, it's not in there yet.
Okay. Uh, was there a migration to run?
Can you go see Can we go read the code
layer output instead of just pasting in
random commands?
>> I don't know. Let's look at diffs.
>> No, can we can we go see what it said to
do? Because it might have had you like
run something before you actually go and
do this.
>> Um, let me pull this up. Okay.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Oh, it wants me to go run the test.
>> No. So, it said it says those work. It
actually, if you scroll up, it actually
ran these for you.
>> And then it says start the demon and
verify migration applies cleanly. So,
you probably have to
Yeah, that's interesting.
Um,
can you just do it into GP AI? Um, or we
can go look in the migrations.go and
just see if it actually added it.
>> I mean, I think it's the title's not
here. So, it's like I I suspect it's not
there.
>> It's definitely not here.
>> So, that's interesting. It's also
interesting like can you uh can we do
something else? Can you in your bun can
you add one more uh parameter to your
end bars or just export like build type
equals experimental cuz this is actually
sharing your prod database for your
stable version and I don't like that.
>> Build type
>> type equals experimental semicolon and
then yeah then run it. This should give
you like a dev database that is
>> I think I'm running experimental dev
build. I would stop.
>> No, you're running the front end in
experimental mode, but not the back end
because it's using your prod database.
We also onboarded Vib into into how to
run this stuff last night. So, uh, some
some speed bumps perhap perhaps
expected.
All right. So, now if you go into debug,
you should have a different database
path. And let's try that SQLite again.
Uh, not here.
Debug.
Oh, why is it still using that database?
I don't like that.
>> Is Is that the right build type?
>> Yeah, that should be right.
>> Spelled experimental wrong.
>> Mine.
>> I spelled experimental wrong.
>> Oh, okay. Nice.
>> Yes. I mean, that should have been
obvious. It loaded a bunch of my
prompts.
I mean also like I said this this to me
is like so sort of debug this like
clearly the database doesn't have any
SQLite
>> so my hunch says
>> nope
um
>> we can look at this code
>> are you sure you spelled it right
experimental well it's like I think this
code is definitely correct but the
problem is we can't validate it because
when you I think when you run the local
demon it falls back to the one that's
already running part of your like prod
instance.
>> Um,
>> when I run this, does it use the prod
database?
>> But why does that matter?
>> Uh, cuz I think that like if there's
already a demon running for your prod
build, it may be basically like cuz this
migration happens when the go back end
spins up. And so if there's already one
running, then it's like not working.
like I just I don't want these things
competing over the same database.
That's the number one thing that I am
quite certain is not the right idea. So
this is an issue with your dev
environment though at the core.
>> Okay. So I mean I have AI generated
titles here.
>> Yeah, it's all coming through.
>> Do you want me to turn off code layer
like close it and then run it through
developing it?
Uh, I don't like that either because
Yeah, mine's doing the same thing. Um,
uh, just in your end set, uh, human
layer database path.
>> Okay. Or
>> just export path equals. Yeah, that's
fine. tilda slash.hum human layer/human
layer experimental db.
>> Uh, you want to send me the command?
>> You're not sharing.
>> We have some We have some questions from
people. I'm not me sharing.
>> That I think should work.
>> And we're getting a bunch of questions
from people actually.
>> People have questions on this show.
That's crazy.
>> That end.
>> Can the research agents panel of cursor
spawn sub agents? I don't know. I don't
think so.
>> Um, that's a good question. Yeah, it
doesn't actually use the sub agents, so
it probably won't work as well. I'm sure
cursor will have sub agents in no time.
I'm sure it's happening.
>> I figured out the problem. It's because
of work trees. Actually, work trees need
a end file that is copied over and that
is not tracked by git. [snorts]
>> Oh, so we did update that script to also
copy in your end file, but I don't know
if that got merged yet.
>> I'll add it to both. Uh, yeah.
>> Oh, wait. Are you running sync layer in
the work tree or are you running it in
your main branch? Cuz that would also do
it. I was running in the work tree, but
I'll run it again in the work tree, but
the work tree definitely did not have
nvars. Uh, let me just make sure I'm not
going to copy and bars and show them on
screen.
>> Yeah, I tested with the database path
and it is working better now. Yeah, we
had this working in the other repo and
some
>> Yeah, David, the go repo is directly
directly in the BAML repo.
>> Uh, you can just but most the go layer
is actually quite thin. So if you need
if we want to add support to stuff and
you have ideas, I would love to take you
up on it.
>> Um
>> yeah, today we're working on on human
layer code, not on BAML. All right. So
you launched it.
>> Uh what is the command called?
>> Did you Wait, did you export that?
>> Did you export it or did you file just
set it? Oh, okay.
Cool.
>> All right, cool. Uh, this is running.
And again, I think like a lot of people
underestimate like like should I be
running this cursor? Maybe. But I don't
have the work to reopening cursor. So,
it's just not worth it. I think my
default behavior as an engineer is I
just use the lowest friction task to go
do it. Like when it comes to like any
sort of coding agent or tool, I always
want to just like have it contextualized
because it just makes me way faster.
>> We're putting a terminal in code layer
soon.
Um,
>> so you can just run it from your from
your uh from your ter code layer session
>> then I might do that but it's really
about contextualizing stuff for me.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You want to keep everything
grouped in the same place. And when you
contact switch you want everything to
get updated.
>> Yeah. It's the same reason what I really
want is I really just want like freaking
like AI chatbot in in Obsidian. That'd
be freaking sick for me when I'm working
on plans.
>> How about Obsidian in your AI chatbot?
Either way, it doesn't really matter. I
just figured it's harder to probably
more import Obsidian.
>> Yeah,
>> because there's just way more code. And
like the UX of editing Obsidian is so
fast and it's so nice.
>> Yeah.
>> Damn, you came around fast on that one.
All right, here we go. This one's going
to be empty.
Amazing. All right, this should have
like launched and done the database
updates and stuff. So, can you Yeah, get
that path and let's run the SQL. Well,
you have to make a session. Well, I
guess we can check the schema.
Well, you killed it.
Yeah, fine.
>> I hate code. I should really be using
warp.
>> All right, it's there. Sick.
>> All right, so make a session and then
like query that field and then
>> No, it's probably in there. I don't need
to do that.
>> No, I want to do that. I want to make
sure this is working because if it's
broken later, I want the confidence that
it was working after phase two.
Sorry, dude.
>> This is how it's done.
>> Well,
>> I'm sorry we don't have two years of
incredible test coverage and our problem
is in a programming language which is
immensely verifiable.
>> Well, I would say there's different
parts of it. Our VS Code extension is
not very verifiable. That's actually
like the hardest part about our system.
>> Uh, cool. All right. Pick a session.
Don't put a title. Yeah.
Amazing. How fast can we do this?
Um,
so what we should see
is
>> Oops.
>> Oh no.
>> I got to cut the stream. Uh, [__]
Um,
>> you want to pause it and go delete that
key real quick? Yes, I do.
>> Love some visual organizational feature
whereby related code layer sessions are
grouped together in the main view. Yes,
nested under a title. Once we have AI
session titles, then we can also have
grouping by themes. We can have
classification and labeling.
Um, I noticed I can get super indignant
when it confidently does something I
later think is obviously stupid. Instead
of treating it okay, yeah, I agree. All
right, I'm going to go find actual
questions
instead of comments.
How do I disable key?
>> Yes, Max. 100% agree. Yeah. Uh being
able to have nested sessions on we're
actually not going to call them projects
because people use projects as like too
big. Project just becomes a bucket of
stuff.
>> Um I think the lowest unit of like
grouping will probably be a task because
for one linear ticket or one GitHub
issue, you will likely have
>> you know one or two researches, one or
two plan sessions and then one or two
implementation sessions. And that's just
to ship one thing. Um, and so that's
kind of the idea of of of of how we we
might also have projects or workspaces
or something, but I think the top level
dimen like the lowest like grouping
dimension is like more like task than
project.
>> Cool. Let me rerun the stream again and
then we'll be back.
>> Nice. Sorry about that, dude.
>> That's fine. The key is now revoked.
>> If you manage to go spend 5 cents on by
open AI account, I'm impressed.
>> Um, yes. The problem is that key has a
lot of spending power,
>> a lot of lot of budget. Yeah, but you
still can't get the throughput.
>> Um, I think you can on that key. Uh, but
in within 1 hour you can do some serious
damage on that key.
>> You can just tell this to keep going.
>> Um, well, first I wanted to Okay, sure.
>> Yeah, you can just tell it to do the
whole plan if you want. Uh, just put
this back on DSP.
>> One second. I want to go look at what's
the command that I have to run.
>> Oh, yeah.
And now we can go run this thing.
Tilda. Layerhuman layer experimental
human layer. Yeah.
Amazing. And then just do select star
from set. Select select AI generated
title from sessions
>> from here.
>> Yeah.
Uh
I think maybe you can only run one query
this way. Oh yeah, there you go. Yeah,
just get rid of the pragma stuff.
>> I understand. I didn't know you can only
run one query from that way.
Maybe there's a flag you need.
>> Nope. You can run multiple. Just
>> Why is this empty?
>> Oh, this was just creating the column,
not doing the backend thing. So, it just
created the column. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So, I'm going to let this rip.
>> Yeah. Throw this back on DSP.
Option Y.
Will you will you turn on the auto
accept flag?
>> Yes, I will.
>> Thanks.
Um, okay. You want to go back to the
other one?
>> Um, I do need to do one more thing. I
need to stop this from running in the
background
because it's going to hot reload on
every file change.
>> That's fine. Is that not fine? Can your
computer not handle that?
>> [snorts]
>> Uh, it can, but it's going to hot reload
calling cloud code over and over and
over again. And you don't want that to
happen as a developer.
>> Sorry. It's going to what?
>> It's just going to call cloud code over
and over again on every single grade
session launch, right?
>> Um,
>> because that's the part
>> only when you go launch a session over
there. Not it's not going to do it on
this one. These two are now sharing like
separate database, separate demon,
separate state. So
>> that's true. Okay.
Let's see what this does. One second.
>> Kind of new here. What is human layer?
How does human layer plug into BAML?
>> Great question. Well, the goal for today
was to put some BAML into human layer.
But, uh, I talked by into doing a
smaller, simpler thing to start. Um, but
once we get the TypeScript demon
working, there will be lots of BAML in
human layer. But, um, human layer plugs
into Yeah, human layer is the ORC. We're
building code layer. Yeah. So, we talk a
lot on this show about AI engineering
and AI pipelines and ended up being like
the first show to start talking a lot
about uh this idea of context
engineering, which was honestly
something that like I will say like I I
made the word, but it was uh mostly come
from spending way too much time talking
to Vib and naming a thing that he uh is
constantly rearticulating in different
ways. Um and so the bridge here is that
uh code layer is a way to apply context
engineering to how you use coding
agents. Um and BAML I would say among
any among many other things is a
framework that makes it really easy to
do really good context engineering and
to test it and to validate and to
iterate on it.
>> Let's see what this does.
Uh keep going.
>> Now I'm stuck. This is why I need to
paralyze. This is why I usually try and
run four things in parallel at once. Uh
because when I don't do this, I get
bored and now I want to go on Twitter.
>> Well, so let's make another plan to
because the third feature you wanted was
like session summaries, right?
>> Can't do that until this this one is
done cuz once it knows how to do AI
stuff, it's way easier to go replicate
that. Doing that from scratch is going
to be silly.
>> Yeah, but we validated the AI parts that
matter.
>> No, because what's going to end up
happening is I want to really leverage
the same plan and the same code that it
generated as a git diff and say here's
the diff. I now want you to take this
diff and then now go study this and then
produce a new feature.
>> That's actually the best way to go do.
>> So you don't want to use the plan. You
you want to use the diff cuz like the
plan's going to be very close to the
diff, but I understand you want to
actually use the diff because
>> the diff is like verifiably true. It's
it just works way better. We do this all
the time. We produce sample git diffs
that are really small features that are
guaranteed to be really generalizable.
And boom. Now you just like tell
everyone to use that PR and that diff
number and that commit ID to say this
diff this commit does this feature
implement a very similar feature to this
one.
>> Makes sense.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm I mean I'm with you. If you want to
get the best results for the least
amount of effort, the get diff will
probably be better.
>> Yeah, it's there you go.
>> Uh ID title AI. Okay, so test. So make
another one that is like you know
refactor the XYZ or whatever.
>> Um
>> in your in your like dev in instance of
code layer.
>> Oh
>> it wants you to launch wants you to
launch a new session. Yeah
>> we should just keep this running.
>> Let's see what it does.
>> Yeah.
>> I think we'll be done soon.
>> Yeah. We've been going for almost almost
two hours.
>> Yes. So, I think we'll be done at right
around the two-hour mark. And if we're
not, I will have pop up because I have
vacation stuff to do today.
>> Okay. Hey, listen. Uh, vacation work's
really important.
>> Vacation.
>> If you do not pick a time to relax and
recharge, your body will pick it for
you.
>> Hey,
help me.
>> Will you make a real prompt like, "Hey,
we're going to re we're going to refac."
Um, I just want to see
>> like a long prompt that needs to be
summarized because otherwise it's just
going to
>> Well, it should still produce a summary,
right?
>> Hey, so that works.
>> Uh, so the summary is just going to be
the prompt itself. So we don't have the
AI generated title being generated here.
>> It's right here.
>> No, it's that column is empty though.
Yeah,
>> only the last column is populated.
>> But it should have that in there. No,
>> no. So the idea of this testing of this
phase is that when you launch a session
the background thing runs and then you
actually get the output from it.
>> Um add generate and store title method.
So it should be storing it. No,
>> I'm saying it should be it thinks it is.
That's the test it's giving you. But the
problem is is that AI generated title is
not actually being populated or it's
taking way too long.
>> Well, we can just see like a debug log
maybe. Um, I think because it's a
process managed by another process, you
might not actually get the HL you might
have to get the HLD logs from a file.
So, click click the little debug panel
>> right here.
>> No, in the in the code layer, you can
get the you can get the path to the log
file.
Um,
it might be in settings.
Yeah, see the uh yeah, the logs actually
you can see the logs in the terminal
console too. If you just command I,
command shift I or whatever in in code
layer, you get you can get the web
console and it'll show.
>> Okay. So, are there any errors here in
the
>> might be okay?
Uh, this is t logs.
>> No, it also includes the demon logs. If
you scroll up, you should see demon logs
in here. Yeah. See,
that's the client that talks to the
demon. This is fine. This is a error
that we're going to get rid of.
Um, scroll down. Can you go to the
bottom? This is way too verbose. also
um
okay so let's go back to the model
imprompt this is why like phase this is
why I split the phases here because if
this doesn't work we need to go debug
this live and I don't want to have
written too much code to have to debug
in one so we know phase one is working
we know phase two made the column so I'm
going to tell it here um
isn't working
uh don't hit send yet Um,
>> one second. Here's here's how I do it. I
try and give it like a
um what are is there any other file that
I can give it?
>> Um,
no, this is this is it. I Yeah, you can
give it the command and you can say like
see the summary isn't populated.
Um, say you may need to add some logs.
>> Oh, interestingly, I think the model
infers that, but we can tell it that.
>> No, I always tell it that I sometimes it
doesn't, and I don't want to wait for it
to figure it out
to see. Yeah.
Uh the only thing other thing I would
tell it is like you like I need to
restart the demon. You can't do it. So
tell me when you've added the logs and I
will restart it for you.
>> Why do you need to restart it? Doesn't
it auto restart?
>> Because the hot reloading doesn't reload
the go process right now, which is also
part of why we're moving to TypeScript
cuz that's a pain.
>> Oh, that's funny.
>> So you need to like control C it and
restart it and have it rebuild the Go
process.
And rather than interrupting it here, I
would just controll X and fork it and
just add that to your original
instructions.
All right.
No, I need to restart the go process.
So when the logs are ready, ask me.
>> All right, fine.
I mean,
>> yeah, I know you can do hot reload and
go, but it's it was it was slow and we
didn't have time to debug it. So, coming
soon.
>> Yeah, we spent a lot of time making
internal tooling really good for
debugging because of this.
>> Yep. Congratulations on having a
three-year-old codebase. We'll we'll get
there eventually.
>> Are we three years old?
>> Two years old, maybe.
>> We start working on BAML in like mid
2023.
>> Yeah, we've done um uh some good
rewrites.
Yeah, we're we're in the middle of that
rewrite which will make all this way
easier.
Put this over on a different window
again
while this is running and then we'll see
what this does.
Yeah,
>> nice. According to this, this thing is
ready.
>> Okay, so you can run another like bun
rundev in in that thing and I think it
should work.
>> V repos.
>> No, it's just it repos. Yeah, it's tilda
repos.
>> Yeah, it's
>> I need to explain Unix to you, dude.
They basically
think where uh
uh that's not that's not how deter
command history bun d-bun rundev
I think this will work. There might be a
port conflict.
>> There's a port.
Okay. Uh yeah,
you
ah oh yeah, you have to probably go
restart the one that was wrong. You did
restart this one. Yeah, let's make
another session.
>> Um
>> refactor the
>> learn new things about this code.
>> Uh specifically how
>> MCP works.
>> Great. Is that sufficient info?
>> Okay.
So, I give it a sec.
Yeah, you can say done
>> now. See what this does. and this sort
of test.
>> I know you got to go in a minute, but
this has been I think this has been
super useful and interesting. And uh I
might ask you to just push all this up
and I'm gonna I'm gonna keep running.
>> Download title logs.
Um
see like this
what I suspect
>> I might be checking the wrong log file
also.
I think maybe our log consolidation
might be busted and it's it's pulling in
the TypeScript demon logs but not the
logs of the process that spawned. Oh,
there you go. Yeah, you are getting the
go structured logs there.
>> I am.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So those those like key
value pairs of logs, those are from the
demon. So you actually have them in your
output there.
Let's try again.
Uh, another request. Uh, let me know
when you are ready
for researching MCP.
Cool.
I'll just tell to try again in there.
Oh, it's actually making changes.
>> Yeah,
that's funny. It is doing like a go
build.
>> This is just a test.
>> Okay.
Uh and then what I will do is I'll make
this testing loop really fast.
Do you not have a CI/CD way to like
create a new session?
>> There is a CLI to create a new session.
Yeah, you can use like uh code layer
launch.
That's funny. It reads as you found
something.
>> That does that look right?
>> I don't think that's Oh, it's working
now. Okay. Okay. So, it just like didn't
put the kick off. Let's here. Click on
that output. Let's see if it got a
title.
>> Yeah, it did. It worked. Amazing.
Um, cool. I would say since you got a
jump and you want to pause like I would
just say like update the plan with what
we learned and then commit everything
and push it.
>> I think phase four is the last phase,
right? So,
>> it's just the front end side. Okay. I
mean, you said you had to go in three
minutes. If you're down to go over like
10 minutes, let's see if we can actually
get working code here
>> and then we'll get this done.
Yeah,
>> I'll start recapping recapping some of
the learnings I guess is like again is
like phase ordering and being able to
test like imagine if we had gone all the
way to the front end and we were
debugging this the scope of what could
be wrong would be way bigger and so
that's why I was like really wanted to
test these things one by one.
>> Yeah, I think we were probably just
doing different levels of testing like I
was just like I would just test the
event stream and if the event stream is
working then I'm pretty happy with it.
[snorts]
But I think it's
>> like if the event stream wasn't working,
like you weren't getting the new title
in, then you wouldn't know if it was the
front end wire to the back end or that
the back end wasn't actually doing the
work properly.
>> Uh uh slash
uh just where what files mention
MCP.
So, this won't trigger a new run through
like because we told it to just inherit
the parent session title. So, this won't
actually
>> Well, this is not the title one. I This
is the Obsidian one that I'm switching
context to. Sorry.
>> Oh. Oh, cool. Okay.
>> I just want to see if it points out an
MTP file and then when it does this.
>> Yeah, you're using Haiku, so it's not
going to follow the instructions.
>> Cool. Or just tell it read one file.
>> Do the research.
>> Okay,
great.
>> Approve.
>> Oh, now it's following the instructions.
>> Uh, I mean, it did before, too. It just
did a GP and then it found everything.
>> Haiku, you so fast.
Yeah, I literally hate using anything
but haiku for that reason for most tasks
because it's just speed. I find speed is
my actual number one alpha.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and then in theory it should work.
Oh, I got to write this.
>> Nice.
>> I got to go here. Default letter
Obsidian.
>> Nice.
All right. Now you should be able to
click it.
You can use O also to open files. Oh
[__] Damn, you shipped it. Let's
[__] go.
>> Yeah,
>> this is a good feature. Oh, I like this.
>> Cool. Um,
get the get the
fun.
I might do the code layer thing and do
it the code way.
Great.
>> And that's what I like. I didn't need
phase commits for that at all. For
example, yeah, that one just worked.
>> Yeah, that one was that one was simple.
That one you just rip through. I mean
that could have all been in one phase
basically.
>> That's what I mean. And I I don't even
mean research in the same way. Like I I
think it's just building an intuition
for what things can work really well and
what things
>> it takes reps.
>> Create create a branch and add all
relevant files.
Not the thoughts.
Cool.
There you go. You got obsidian. And now
this thing is
Yes. Oh, this so annoying. I said yes
already.
This is why I hate this stuff.
Um,
>> I mean, again, it just takes reps. You
realize yes doesn't work, so you start
typing instead. You say like, great, do
the next phase.
And it's takes an extra 3 seconds of
your time.
>> But no, I mean, this is one of the
things we're working on a lot is like
there's a lot of like oral tradition
that goes into this stuff and like vibes
and instinct that you have to develop.
And we're trying to make it easier for
like people who haven't like you and me
who haven't spent years talking to
models all day and like really have an
intuition about it. How do we make the
like fewer foot guns that just kind of
like make it work even if you're not an
expert at LLM? How do we make the
planning and the implementation actually
like pretty straightforward? People can
get the hang of research pretty easily
because research is like the the the
only thing you get wrong with research
is like baking in too much
implementation stuff and even that for
smaller stuff is fine.
I think my my biggest uh my biggest
gripe here is like
it just I feel like sometimes it feels
like uh the answer is it's my fault as a
developer. But honestly, when I think
about developer tooling, my biggest
thing is I think the tooling should be
doing as much of the work as possible.
>> Yep. You got to you got to let the AI do
the things that the AI is good at. You
got to let the tooling do the
deterministic things that like you know
you're going to want to do every time.
and like make sure the user is only
doing the high leverage human stuff
which is like thinking and design and
systems architecture.
>> Well, that's what I mean. For example,
like I'll just give you like a tooling
feature here. If you know I wrote a
really short response and it's like
affirmative in some way and then this
thing was asking me to proceed and then
like really quickly it just asks me to
proceed again that you could in you
could auto inject yes on my behalf.
>> Yeah.
>> As part of as as someone building
toolink.
>> Yeah. almost like uh cursor cursor tab
complete but for prompting the model not
for the code that it generates.
>> It's not even it's not even tab complete
it's just like it's just it's basically
helping the model steer in the direction
that I want it to especially if it's
running in the background process. You
probably don't want to do that if I'm
here.
>> Yeah.
>> But if I am outside I'm running
something else and like it's a great
thing to go do.
>> Oh, it made a PR. Nice.
>> You want to pop it open and just give it
a quick scan?
Um,
I'll leave this pull the files. Yeah,
I'll I'll review this and we may pull it
down and make a couple more tweaks, but
>> I'm probably going to delete the This is
just the built-in agents that you added
just so we could make sure you were
using the non-thoughts versions of the
of the prompts just because that's a
bunch of extra stuff to set up.
>> Yep.
>> Cool. This does the trick.
Yeah,
>> I mean, like I said, we watched the
implementation phase by phase, so I'm
pretty confident in this one, but we'll
we'll have Kyle do a review.
>> For this one, we didn't. For the
Obsidian one, we just vibe the whole
thing.
>> We skimmed the plan, though. We changed
parts of the plan.
>> We haven't been looking the face by
face, but
>> you let me know when you merge it. Uh,
I'm going to clean out these really
fast.
>> Yep.
>> When I go run this,
what is this doing? Sick, dude.
>> Yeah. And this thing I think will should
just work. Phase four, my hunch says
will just work. Uh
>> just go do it. Let's just go test it
real quick.
>> Yeah.
Well,
>> the front end part you can just leave it
running like this. That that part will
hot reload. You don't need to you don't
need to restart it.
>> Yeah. So, we'll see what this does.
>> Yep.
This is fun, man. I'm already getting a
bunch of like DMs and Slack messages
that people really like this episode.
>> That's cool.
Once this launches,
>> let's go into here.
I hate that there's no loading indicator
here.
>> It's coming. It's one of those tickets
that I'm like, I thought we already did
that three times.
>> Um
Oh, you're talking about loading on the
title.
>> Yep.
Uh I got to correct the database.
>> SQLite.
>> Oh my god. That's the key. You deleted,
right?
>> Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, it's got deleted, so I don't care.
Go at it.
>> Yeah, go try to use it. Equal. We got to
fix your shell history.
>> Um, I should use oxide.
>> Okay.
>> Uh, where is this? I gave it the CLA
command. This, see, this is the other
reason that I find like using new tools
to be really hard because then when I do
that, it's very hard for me to find uh
it's very hard for me to adapt.
>> Yeah.
>> It's a discontinuous innovation.
>> Exactly. So, this one did not trigger
this.
>> It did.
>> Nope.
>> Researching MCP. It did. It made a
title, but it's not showing up in the
front end.
So we might be missing the fallback
logic of like hey it should be showing
the AI title.
>> No,
>> just say like the AI title got written
to the database but it's not showing in
the front end.
>> The AI title is in the database but it's
not showing in the front end.
Um,
>> yep. Is that a logic bug or a
in the event stream or a front end bug?
>> Yeah. And the other thing I'm realizing
is that I we didn't update the open API
schema which means like we're not
actually sending down the new thing.
It's
>> Are you sure?
>> Yes. Greater than uh default
placeholder.
Can we look at the diff and look at the
open API schema
and cursor?
>> It it had in it in its spec at least.
Oh, but I can't look at the freaking
history against against main because
this is only one commit
graph.
>> Uh
uh open API. Where is this? This one
>> yeah just search for AI just search for
title or that works.
How do I see the last name? There we go.
This is the last one here
>> from Yeah, I don't think I don't think
our I think this is actually an issue
with our plan.
>> Oh, it's doing phase five.
>> Oh, the event is being published.
>> It's just doing the streaming, which
means like if you close it or restart
it, it's not going to stream down.
>> I see. I see. I see. The front end just
isn't handling that event yet. Yeah,
they were doing the I think we had it do
the SSSE streaming and the testing for
SSE is like curl the event endpoint and
make sure the event comes down.
>> I see. Cool.
>> Yeah, which we could still test if you
wanted to.
>> That's too much work. [laughter]
>> That's actually why the manual
verification I don't actually do most of
the time.
>> You would have skip this and just
combine them into one phase. Yeah,
that's fine.
>> It's also like depending on your timing
and your tolerance.
>> For example, when we work when we work
with BAML, um
>> yeah,
>> that's how we do it. We've actually done
a lot of work to create these like
snapshot tests.
>> Oh yeah, you were showing this last
week.
>> Yeah. And like I actually don't actually
vibe this most of the time. I just let
the model go and do the thing it needs
to do.
>> Yeah.
>> Why is this not letting me type?
>> Agent terminals are read only.
[laughter]
>> That's an agent terminal. Um, what I let
it do is I let the model run. And while
it's running, I actually really quickly,
what the snapshot test does is it
creates like a new diff. So like I'll
show you what it does. Um,
uh, I I'm making a whole new repo for
us. Uh, BMA language
cargo test-list.
What is it?
L
I forgot. I don't actually have a list
test
in cargo.
And what I end up doing is I'll I'll
show how this runs really fast
is when this test runs, I'll run like
basic types. Yep.
basic
basic types
when I run this test from here and I
let's say I edit this file to like put
like a get status to
and when I run this it actually produces
like a really quick diff and not only
does it produce a diff you'll notice
that it creates a file on the disk that
it can go
>> snapshot
>> exactly for the specific ones that
failed so now what the model can do is
it can actually go compare and contrast
and actually like be like, "Oh, this is
the part that's broken."
>> And you'll notice that we actually we
actually did other things. Not only do
that, we actually named the phases in
order.
>> So like obviously phase two fails if
phase one fails
>> and it's easy for the model. Oh, I
should fix phase one before I fix phase
two. It's it makes inferencing the model
way easier.
>> Yeah.
>> So these are small things that we have
seen make a huge difference in
incorrectness.
>> Cool.
Uh, how's our how's our implementation
going?
What? Yeah. Can we look at this? What is
it doing? Is it actually regenerating
the SDKs?
>> I have no idea.
>> We don't have search on here yet. It's
coming. For what it's worth, Ghosty also
doesn't have search.
>> I
>> People give Mitchell a lot of [__] for
that.
>> What I will say is as a developer, I
don't care.
>> Oh, look. It is. Yeah, it's doing the
fallback. Okay, scroll up.
>> Yeah. I just want to make sure because
sometimes it will
>> sometimes it will not update the open
API scheme. It'll just like edit both
sides of the contract which is like very
wrong. Like it technically will work but
it's very wrong.
>> Um I think this is the wrong way to go
look at this.
>> Sure.
>> It's just easier to go read this
>> uh session title
>> lib demon types.
Okay, that's the event type.
Yeah, it didn't update the open API
spec. Okay, if we had more time, I would
be like, this is a great time to re
steer of like backing out some of what
had happened and like actually like how
do you edit a plan in flight when you
realize something was wrong after three
phases of implementing?
>> Do you want me to rerun it or?
>> Yeah, let's try to restart probably
because it go
>> No, don't restart it. Don't restart it.
>> Whatever.
>> Stop restarting it.
It's fine.
>> Building hot reload is very very
important uh for developer workflows
especially agent systems that require
like UI testing.
>> I mean the UI part does hot reload.
That's why I said don't restart it.
>> But it changed go code. Did it not?
>> Did it? I don't think so. with types
types I go
refresh this
command R
Yeah. Yeah. So, that's working.
Yeah. Uh, it seems like the title's not
I mean, we can tell the model this like
the title's not being brought down. This
is also the other thing is like you get
to the end of phase and something's not
working. Usually, if it's small, you can
vibe your way out of it.
Um,
so a
Can I can I can I tell you what to say
here that's actually going to get you
the result you want fastest?
>> Uh, one second. Let me add this in. All
right, now go.
>> Um, I think you need to update open
API.yamel and regenerate the types to
make sure that it comes down from the
demon when fetching sessions.
Oh, that's going to be I don't know.
That's funny.
It that is not going to work, is it?
I mean, yeah, I wouldn't have put that
whole image in there because you just
used like thousands of tokens for a
thing you could have told the model. I
it I think it gives a model affirmation
that again it's more about speed for me.
Um and I'm I found images have been a
great way to communicate UI stuff.
>> Cool.
>> Uh let's see if it actually figures out
how to regenerate the types. Okay,
fantastic.
>> So why why are we even doing the title
logic here? Shouldn't it just send the
title correctly when it fills it out?
>> So what's happening is it's launching it
and then it should be sending down an
SSE event. I don't know if the SSSE we
don't use SSE for a lot so I don't trust
it but also like what I want is like
even if you get the SSSE event if you
refresh the page it should be able to
pull it from the database and the
problem is like the session object and
the contract is not getting updated and
so like maybe it'll update live if you
stay on the page for long enough because
we want title AI generated title and
user title and the fallback logic lives
on the front end.
>> Oh is that how you do it?
>> Yeah and yeah that was what's in the
plan. Uh, you need to be running Docker
to do the type generation.
>> Oh my god.
So, I have a different idea. Instead of
doing the type generation, we don't
actually have to do that, right? What I
can't
>> It's just going to It's going to go hack
around it. It's going to go find a
workaround.
>> But can't I just make the go part just
fill in the
>> That's what it's doing.
>> It's going to go find the like go store
and like add the JSON tag to it.
Also, you're about to get autocompacted,
which means that everything's going to
go to [__]
>> Well, I think that's one of the things I
will challenge you on. Um, I agree.
Autoco compaction is usually bad, but
sometimes it's not too bad.
>> Sometimes it's okay, but again, like I
don't want to sit here and hope that
it's going to work.
>> Um,
oh, I think I'm I'm talking about
something different than what it's doing
right now. Instead of even modifying the
API spec, can't they just make the title
field contain the AI generated title or
the user generated title?
>> Um,
no, because uh yeah, you could do the
oring on the back end if you wanted to.
>> How about we do that?
>> Let's see. Let's just see where this
gets here.
>> Oh, see it's trying to do the generation
again. It's like already forgotten that
that doesn't work because Docker's not
running here. I'll I'll I'll I'll
>> You're going to hit a compaction, dude.
>> Open a uh instead of
>> I have an idea. How about we do a fork?
>> Yes. Fantastic.
>> Oh, I realized I can't actually do that
because
I don't want to edit these files
and edit a bunch of random stuff.
>> No. What do you mean? It's not going to
edit anything.
>> Well, didn't it edit all these files?
>> Like, didn't it edit this file?
AI title.
[sighs]
AI generated title. Uh, is that not in
here?
It's going to be with the underscores,
dude.
Use the underscores.
>> What do you mean?
>> AI underscore generated. Yeah,
>> it's not yet.
>> Yeah, it hasn't added it here yet.
>> I'm going to delete this.
I'm going delete this.
I'm going try again. I'll use your fork
feature.
>> Yeah. So fork that one and just give it
very specific instructions instead of I
think you need to update the open API.
>> Um in the back end when
you return the session
the title should be the or of
UI user title or the uh AI title.
Sure.
>> The summary fallback
we can we can do in the front end.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> I hope it doesn't read that picture
again.
>> It probably will.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. There you go.
Like I think it's just way easier if the
back end is sending out events for this
rather than the front end doing it.
>> Yeah. I mean I don't I don't like from
an architecture perspective of having
two different fallbacks in two different
places. But in the interest of getting
this working and like viewing something
cool end to end and then like this is
the idea is like make it work and then
figure out your test loop and then
refactor.
>> Yeah, it's interesting that you do it
there. I would actually do it purely in
the back end for everything. Why why
doing the front end or the back end?
>> Because we may want to display both like
what you display is I think is client
logic. It's not business logic.
>> I see
>> there's an argument for either way. It
probably doesn't matter. I think it was
like it was like cool whatever works. I
think even in the moment we were having
this conversation, there was probably a
like, yeah, it doesn't matter. Just pick
one.
>> There you go.
>> Easy.
All right. Go. Uh, you got to Now you
have to restart it because you're making
go line changes, though.
>> Yeah. Once this is done, though.
>> Yeah.
Oh, the RPC handlers don't matter.
Um, but then the event stream I think is
not working, but everything else I think
should be.
>> Yeah. And this is why I was like, I want
to do the event stream part last because
I just want to make sure this works
first.
Amazing.
All right, you can go restart it.
Let's go. Moment of truth.
And what have we learned? Let's see.
>> What we learned is that if we get really
close to solving something, we can get
Vib to sacrifice an extra 20 minutes of
his vacation.
>> Yes, that's basically [laughter] the key
takeaway.
I do really like code. It's really hard
for me to uh uh it's really hard for me
to step away from code. I freaking love
code of all kind. It doesn't even matter
what it is. I just love coding.
>> Hey, look at that.
>> Well,
>> it's there because now it's just pulling
it from the database. So, any one of
these that has the thing in the
database, it's going to work.
>> There you go. It popped into right here.
>> Oh, it came in with the stream. Nice.
>> Sick. Ship it.
>> Ship it. I mean, I'm going to pull this
down and clean up a couple things. But
yeah, this is I'm probably going to
rework it to use the open API just so
the pattern matches, but
there's a slash commit command if you
want.
It's fine.
>> Let's see what this does. Ah, that's too
much work
>> to run the slash command. Yeah,
it's I think I think you I think you're
one of the people that is very adaptable
in your workflow. And I think one of the
things to recognize here is like it's
very hard for most people to really
change their workflow. Like in theory,
yes, we should all be doing the optimal
things, but most people don't want to
anneal like most developers that have
experience can't just like anneal to a
new workflow [snorts] very fast.
I mean, it is definitely like I mean,
that's what cursor is good at is like
it's a slightly faster way of doing the
same thing I was already doing versus
like this is very much a what like the
crossing the chasm guy calls like
discontinuous innovation.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I actually think you probably have a
similar thing with BAML, right? Where
it's like, okay, I don't just use a new
library. I actually have to change the
way I think about structuring my code.
>> Yeah. Or like
>> it's like valuable to make that hit, but
it takes longer to get to like over the
first hill there.
>> Yeah. Uh exactly and you really need I
think you need to anchor on the one use
case that is like super applicable for
it in any one use case. So like for
example like in this scenario like like
I said sometimes I find it super useful
to just uh switch over to cursor and try
out the same thing because they load my
cloud code commands anyway.
>> Yeah. But like one of the things that
curs like uh let me tell you like part
of the reason why I found that was
actually because of some of this stuff
like oh I don't have it in this one but
I think I have it in my other one
3. Part of the reason why that's
interesting is like they do some stuff
like this where they just rename stuff
and that is just useful for me as a
developer to go think about and think
about what I really want out of this.
So I think there's small things like
that that make a huge difference.
Uh and if you can get like the workflow
really good for one or two specific use
cases, I think it becomes a really
exciting way to change habits. But like
if if I have to be perfect and prompting
every single time, that's really hard as
a developer.
On the other hand, you now have a poll
request
uh for new features.
>> Amazing. This was a blast, dude. Thank
you for uh thank you for shipping. Sick.
What' you learn?
>> My main thing that I learned is like we
code. Uh this repo is sadly not public.
>> This is our experimental testing ground
where we're we're working on some new
stuff.
>> My main thing that I really learned was
just that it's it's just uh how do I
phrase it? Uh it's interesting seeing
other people's coding styles.
Like I think that's just always
fascinating to me. Like there's small
differences in the way people develop.
And u I think the other thing to really
see is just that the way that people
communicate about code is probably very
important because there's probably some
bias that the models have that they take
advantage of in some way.
>> I like it. Um yeah, I think uh I I
enjoyed having you push back on like,
hey, maybe we don't need to do that much
context engineering. Maybe we can just
blast this through. And that reminder
that like you should always be like, you
know, we got to get our jobs done and
like do what you think will work, but
also like if you're not constantly
firing like way higher or way lower in
terms of how much work you do to do a
feature, you won't learn like how to how
to move. And it's like there's so many
dimensions of working differently in the
AI world in terms of like different
models, different CLIs, different tools,
different amounts of context
engineering, different sets of prompts.
And it's like I think the challenge is
either like people find one thing that
works and they are afraid to change
anything and they get stuck there. But I
I think it's really valuable to like
pick a dimension and explore along it
until like I don't know I rotate through
like one week I'll try different tools,
one week I'll try different levels of
context engineering, one week I'll try
different repos. Like you got to you got
to like pick a dimension and then eval
across that dimension for your own
intuition.
>> That's really Yeah, I think I do it
probably a slightly different way. It
sounds like you're much more scientific
in the way that you experiment. I
>> still it's still all vibes, but I try to
be intentional about like locking most
of the dimensions and focusing on one at
a time.
>> I think the way I always do it is I
there's so many different dimensions
that I actually try not to be I lock
anything. I just say like I just snap to
totally different workflows and my the
main thing that I actually try and do
now is especially when new models come
out, which is very recently right now.
It's very temp it's like temporal right
now that it just happened. During that
specific time period, I actually just
like reset all expectations and
completely I start like your approach of
like, hey, don't let the model do that.
I actually do the exact opposite when
new model comes out.
>> How much can the model do and what what
does it still suck at?
>> Exactly. Because my theory, like as
someone that's building BAML
specifically, is I'm always like, hey,
look, what is um
what do I think developers are going to
build in the next two or three years?
And if I ever lock that in into what I
the developers can build today, we will
build a feature into BAML that is
pointless.
>> Yeah, you have to be looking forward.
>> I always got to look forward. And that's
why like in even with coding agents or
the easiest way for me to just reset my
my brain.
>> It's like like hey, nope. Let's just
live try and reset this from scratch and
like make no assumptions and just push
the model capability as much as
possible.
>> I love it. Sick. Amazing. This has been
a blast.
>> All right, Dex. Always fun to see you.
Uh the live recording will be up in
about a week, but for anyone interested,
go sign up and you'll get notified.
>> What are we talking about next week?
>> Uh evals on images, I believe.
>> Multimotals.
>> Yes.
>> I love it.
>> All right, dude. This was super fun.
Thank you. Thanks everyone for watching.
Catch you later.